Õpetaja: Nii kuulsite üldse? Ee teil ekraanil peaks olema ka tegelikult näha mingi niukene pilvesümbol ja punane mummukene.
Õpetaja: Kuskil Ee. Nüüd Palun aidakene. Aidake mul ka meeles hoida kahte asja. Aga kui me teeme pausi, siis on mõistlik mul korraks panna seal see recording niiöelda Pausi peale pole mõtet võtta linti neid.
Õpetaja: Ee, mingi viieteist minutilise pause, et kui keegi kodust vaatab midagi järgi, siis tuleb see koht, kus Ta peab lihtsalt nagu kuidagi opereerima. On ju, et mõistlikum on panna pausile aga, Siis Veelgi tähtsam on see et, kui pausilt Tagasi tulen Et ma panen alati rekordima.
Õpetaja: Mul vahel ununeb see Ja siis. On nagu see, et me teeme mingi jäpa jäpa ja me õpime mingeid asju Siis lõpuks. Keegi avastab kuskilt, et kuule, et ei rekordigi. See on nagu see, et okei, midagi läks veits kaduma. Vaata rekordingus
Õpetaja: ja Siis mis ma teen lõunaajal Ma panen ta stopi peale. See siis tähendab seda, et sellest tuleb nagu video üks ja siis ta hakkab Nagu vaikselt taustalist renderdama. Ja õhtul, kui ma vajutan teist korda stoppi, siis ta põhimõtteliselt hakkab teist videot renderdama, aga kumbagi kahjuks ennem ei saa näha. Kui mõlemad vist on ära trenderdaad,
Õpetaja: siis mis me videodega veel teeme?
Õpetaja: Me teeme videodega niimoodi. Et ee. Iga päev saab ee sellest videost võtta, siis. Ee. Ütleme siis kõik, mis nagu tekst läheb peale. Ee, tekib tegelikult Niukene tekstifail.
Õpetaja: Ja mida me eelmise grupiga tegime? Ma tegin Cloud is niukse Skill I. Põhimõtteliselt, Mis siis ütleb, et Ei, mina annan sulle ette. Ee, tekstifaili, mis on ee niiöelda Aa Video Zoomi video niiöelda.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, ee, põhimõtteliselt ütlen, et Ole hea, nagu et tee nüüd sellest Niukene kokkuvõtte fail Ee, tee ilusti ülesse nagu kõigepealt väike sisukord koosampidega, kus on nagu need video ee minutid peal. Et Kust videost Mingi üks või teine asi hakkab,
Õpetaja: et kõik Teemad, mis me läbi käime Ta siis teeb põhimõtteliselt niiöelda mingisugused materjalid.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida on? Siis? Ee, suht hea pärast nagu vaadata ja siis On Need timesimed? On ka kenasti juures, et, ee, kui mingi teema nagu huvitab. Ja hiljem, siis te saate ja see kõik. Ma panen Reposse juurde. See sama projekt, mida me teeme. Üks eraldi kaust,
Õpetaja: et, ee, väga mugav ja toimiv lahendus on siis, ee, saada niuke kiire ülevaade erinevatest teemadest, mida me oleme käsitlenud. Ja kui vaja, siis otsida ka ülesse ka vastavad videod. Ma olen isegi ükskord ise päriselt seda korra kasutanud. Mul oli midagi vaja veits taastada ja Timmida Ja siis. Ma sain aru, et
Õpetaja: ee, vähemalt videode peal on mingisugused asjad olemas
Õpetaja: Ja võib isegi tegelikult siis ee, sammu veel kaugemale minna. Notebook lm I. Olete kasutanud käsitüsti mitte keegi.
Õpetaja: Okei, väga hea platvorm. Ee, see on Siis Google oma Ee notebook Lem I Nagu põhiline. Nagu erisus, on see, et see on selline koht, kus ee, sa saad visata Põhiliselt mistahes dokumendid. Ee, on need. Pdf Id on need. Ee, Worldfilid.
Õpetaja: Ee, Md failid, mis? Mida meie Kasutame siin projektis kirjafailid, põhimõtteliselt,
Õpetaja: ja Siis, ee, seal on nagu see lahe asi, et sa saad siis nagu lihtsalt ise näiteks klikkida. Ära vaata, kui sul on mingi kakskümmend Dokumenti või mis iganes sa saad ära klikkida, et. Ee, mida sa selles konkreetses Hetkel, nagu tahad, nagu kuidagi aktiivsena hoida, ja siis sa Saad seal Chat ida. Näiteks sa saad öelda nagu, et. Okei, räägime mingitest asjadest.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on nagu see, et ta arvestab nende andmete pealt, mis on, mis sina oled sinna pannud. Ee, sellest Chatist Ja Ja siis mitte nagu oma niiöelda mudeli pealt. Aga mis seal on Veel on igasugused lahedad asjad. Nagu näiteks mind, Map,
Õpetaja: Oletame, et sul on mingi Ma ei tea. Ee, mingi aa. Mingi seadus. Näiteks mingi Pikk seadustik, paragrahvid, asjad. Mind map on niimoodi, et ta põhimõtteliselt visualiseerib nagu teemade kaupa ära, et kuidas seal mingid asjad on seotud,
Õpetaja: siis Mis sa veel on? Seal on näiteks see, et tee mulle näiteks nendest konkreetsetest failidest. Podcast?
Õpetaja: Siis ta teeb audio podcast I, kus kaks inimest ja räägivad nagu päris podcast ist. Siis saab isegi niimoodi teha. Isegi ei ole pruugi nagu võimalik mikrofon
Õpetaja: ee võimalik seal aktiveerida, Nad teevad podcast. I sa samal ajal ütlevad nagu. Ja siis sa saad küsida. Ja siis nad nagu, ma ei tea, järsku nagu on see Nagu live is. Kuidagi, et. Hei, väga. Tore, Rain. Vaata, et sa nagu minuga räägid. Vaata, ja see on nii hea küsimus, mis sa Küsid aga vastust mul Ei, ole. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kas nad on täiesti õige.
Õpetaja: See on täiesti õigus ee. Mis seal veel on? Ee, mulle meeldib Video kokkuvõte. Vot see on üks parimaid. Ee, Ta teeb ise niiöelda Mingid visuaalid, selgitused ja muud asjad teeb ee. Teeb nagu niukse videokokkuvõtte. Et tegelikult päris päris hea.
Õpetaja: Ja minu mõte on see, et me võiksime tegelikult seda asja. Tegelikult, Ee, üsna. Nagu maksimaalselt ära kasutada, et Need teemad ja materjalid, mis me niiöelda läbi käime. Me ju tegelikult võiksime natuke nagu näha. Vaeva. Et tekitada veel
Õpetaja: nendest ee. Ütleme niiöelda Meie, ee, niiöelda koolituse materjalidest. Veel materjali mis on juba natukene lühemad, lihtsamad seeditavad ja kokkuvõtlikumad ja ka juba illustratsiooniga.
Õpetaja: Ee, et selles mõttes Me võiksime
Õpetaja: ee hakata, siis genereerima neid asju. Aga ma ei tahaks teha seda niimoodi, et ainult. Mina üksinda jään seda tegema nagu iga õhtu. Ee, pigem. Ma mõtlen, et äkki teeme siis niukse variandi, et ee, mõningate asjadega teeme stiilis, et kes on see klassi korrapidajad ta puhtaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, et siis saate ise ka harjutada neid asju. Et. Ee, kordamööda. Võibolla saame teha neid asju, Mis te sellest mõttest arvate,
Õpetaja: et Muidu on nagu see, et tekib see väsimus. Ära vaata, et üks ei jaksa. Vaata pealgi. Siis on natuke nagu see asi ka et seal hästi natukene peab jälgima, et Millal see Zoomi video ära reenerdab, onju? Ma tavaliselt lähen õhtul koju ja mul on nagu rämedalt palju asju teha. Vaata, et kuna sa nüüd natukene seda jagada. Vaata, siis on võibolla veits lihtsam, sest et ega mina neid materjale ei vaja,
Õpetaja: Tegelikult mõnele materjale. Aga teile oleks ju tegelikult hea. Pluss tegelikult õppida nagu sellist lähenemist, et kuidas endal mis tahes asju, Ee, saab tegelikult Ee, teha palju selgitavamas või või igasugused. Ee, head võimalused. As we go. Me teeme neid asju läbi ja proovime. Vaata, kuidas välja tuleb Onju?
Õpetaja: Aga ma arvan, et me võiksime seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ja see on täiesti tavaline tasuta konto. Vot seal ongi. Selline Konks on ka, et Sa saad. Sa saad kõike asju nagu ööpäeva jooksul. Kolm renderdada. Näiteks kolm podcasti. Kolm video, kolmap I. Nad on nagu niimoodi ära piiranud, Aga teil on nagu päris kahekümne Nelja tunni. Mingi tricker, Vaata, et kahekümne Nelja tunni pärast saab nagu uuesti,
Õpetaja: et, ee, kõike neid, asju, Mida mina näitan. Tegelikult saab teha. Vaata, et, ee, et umbes Nii
Õpetaja: võiks ju nii proovida, eksole?
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, Screenshare on mul olemas. Vist on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme siis lahti. Intellig.
Õpetaja: Mul ei olegi ta veel lahti. On siis vahepeal restart olnud
Õpetaja: Ee ja siis esimene Asi, millega me võiks ee, tegeleda, on see, et. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee. Kohe vaatame.
Õpetaja: Noh, kohe kui ta üles ärkab
Õpetaja: vaikselt ja seda teeb igal juhul.
Õpetaja: Kas te kõik vajutasite seda nuppu juba endale, ka, onju?
Õpetaja: Sa võid seda vajutada praegu. See ei ole veel nii temaatiline asi, aga Pigem pigem juba vajutada. Jah,
Õpetaja: jah, ee, taustal. Mis ta teeb, ongi, siis see, et neil toode on siis eelkõige mõeldud Ee eelkõige ta on mõeldud Java ja Gottlin i kirjutamiseks. Keele mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ja. Aga ta on natukene. Nende selline toode, mis tegelikult taustal toetab päris palju muid Keeli ka. Isegi püütonit oleks siin võimalik vist jooksutada ja nii edasi. Meil tegelikult on eraldi tooted. Näiteks jaoks on neil ee, püütoni jaoks On neil
Õpetaja: siis Java jaoks on neil ka endal see. Ja nad on selle toote nimetanud. Intellige Ultimate.
Õpetaja: Noh, see nagu kõlab küll nagu See on nagu üks relv kõige vastu. Aa, ja see natukene nagu ongi, et tegelikult ee, veebiarenduseks. On teil niuke toode enne nagu Web Storm.
Õpetaja: Aga me kasutame põhimõtteliselt seda nii front I kui ka jao jaoks, sest et ta saab küllaltki hästi sellega hakkama, et nagu ei Ole vaja eraldi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et. Noh. Teised on nagu spetsialiseerinud. Päris kõike nagu see ei ei toeta nagu absoluutselt kõike, et neil ikkagi noh, jaoks on ikkagi oma toode Vaata
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja teiste keelte jaoks Teised tooted. Koo jaoks on neil mingisugune oma toode. Neil on terve rodu Neid Chatbrains on siis ettevõte.
Õpetaja: Ee, et nemad siis nagu teevad seda ee võistlevad nad siis siukeste suurte tegijatega nagu ja mingid muud asjad, Vaata, mis on ka tasuta. Vaata, on ju? Aga see Ultimate on siis selles mõttes nende tasuline toode.
Õpetaja: Et Kui te aktiveerite selle Ultimate, Siis tähendab, et seal kõik need ägedad kellad ja viled. Seal on mingid mugavusasjad, mida te isegi võibolla ei taju. Vaata näiteks andmebaasi database Teema on seal eraldi. Ee, siis serveri käivitamine, Serveri käivitamine. Mingid väikesed asjad, mida ma kohe ei oskagi nimetada, sest ma ei, ma ei teagi, mis need on. Sest mul on kogu aeg see ultimate.
Õpetaja: Kui mul ei oleks seda ma ise kasutan ka tasuta kivõtteid Kui mul ei oleks, seda siis ma oleks nõus. Kas kui see viisteist dollarit kuus maksma vaata? Selles mõttes on hea töö eest, kuigi nüüd on Juba natukene nagu küsitav.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles mõttes, et kogu see Ai värk. Vaata, et, noh, mõte on see, et sa saad progeda seal väga Mõnusalt ja mugavalt, Aga kuidagi vähemaks hakkab jääma see nagu klõbistamine.
Õpetaja: Ee, et ee, et selles mõttes nemad on ka nagu natukene sellele, et Nad peavad kuidagi põhimõtteliselt Ee, et mis? Miks ikkagi inimene peaks nagu ostma endale selle Ultimate.
Õpetaja: Okei, no siin on ikkagi ka paljud need Andmebaasid ja igasugused muud mugavused. Võibolla See isegi hoiab
Õpetaja: ee Kasutaja. Harjumused on üldse kõvemad Asjad, Et kui sa oled millegiga juba harjunud, ega Siis on nagu keeruline kuidagi ennast ee ümber harjutada. Minu naine on parim näide sellest.
Õpetaja: Võibolla räägin ruttu selle vaheloo Ära vaata, et ee, Kui ma tutvusin temaga, siis ee, siis ma panin tähele, et ee, ta kasutab. Ta kasutas Internet Explorer I, et selleks ajaks oli Juba Microsoft teinud oma. Mis on siis Chrome? Chrome I Baasil browser.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja siis arendajana. Mina näiteks vihkan niukseid inimesi nagu minu naine,
Õpetaja: ja Võin seda öelda. See On niimoodi, et. Ee, et, ee. Kui näiteks mingid suur korporatsioonid ja asjad ütlevad, tehke meile veebilehekülge infosüsteem, siis ju On küsimus, et mida ta peab toetama. Noh, millest me räägime? Mobiil
Õpetaja: ee, android. Mis versioonid? Ee, iphone. Räägime nüüd päris deskropi brauseritest, onju, Et millest me räägime? Võiks olla ühesugune. Võiks olla chromy. Sajasugune võiks olla safari Ühesugune onju.
Õpetaja: Ja siis Ee Vanasti oli ikka niimoodi, et Siis prilliti see list. Vaata, nagu põhimõtteliselt nendest brauseritest. Vaata, nagu mis peaks toetuma. Ja see on protsendid all vaata ja siis seal näitab, Niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: vanasti oli, et internet Explorer maailmas. Statistika järgi. Hetkel on kasutajaid täpselt veel kaks protsenti. Vaata, onju kaks protsenti, aga siis korporatsiooni Käest küsitakse, et. Noh, et kolme ära vaata. Ei, ei, kõiki
Õpetaja: Nagu ainult kaks protsenti maamuna. Inimese veel kasutab, onju Noh, me räägime palju aastaid tagasi. Ja. Ja
Õpetaja: et, ee, loomulikult. Ee klient tahab alati. Vaata, et. Ja. Ja iga kõike peab toetama absoluutselt ka seda kahte protsenti,
Õpetaja: Ja Siis ongi nagu see minu naine. Nagu meie käest toksis seal. Aa, meie suhte algusaegadel. Seal interneti. Ma ei suutnud seda uskuda. Aa, Mõtlesin, et miks. Miks sa seda Kasutad. Nagu. Miks sa Chrome I kasutada või ei? Siin on kõik niimoodi. Timm, juba vaata. Kasuta harjumusi. Vaata, siin. Ma tean kõike, kuidas on.
Õpetaja: Ma muidugi sain veel rohkem teada. Milline inimene ta on. Siis, kui ma nägin esimest korda, kuidas Ta googeldab
Õpetaja: tema. Siis googeldab niimoodi. Vot Google taas on edasi läinud. Ee, märksa paremaks on asjad näinud.
Õpetaja: Tema siis guugeldas niimoodi, et ee, Ta Tegi internetist lahti. Ee, seal ei olnud isegi homepage sätitud. Klõbistas sealt ülevalt aadressi. W w punkt neti punkt E e No see Enamvähem tuli ettevaata, kui juba klõbistasid.
Õpetaja: Ta läks netipunkt. Eesse netipunkt E. Keegi ei mäleta, et on sinna piisavalt vanu inimesi. Jah, sinine on ju siiamaani on alles ju. Ja siis ta läks sinna. Neti punkt eesse Siis ta läks sinna. Sellesse. Netipunkt E otsingusse läks. Ta kirjutas sinna Google,
Õpetaja: siis ta ütles. Okei, siis ta läks klõpsuga. Google Dot, Com I. Ja siis ta hakkas nagu kirjutama, mida ta otsib,
Õpetaja: või Ütleme pühamööristus Nagu et nagu
Õpetaja: normaalsest Browser ist aadressi reaale. Paned selle otsingusõna. Ja Põm We Go Onju
Õpetaja: kuidas? No näed, on neid inimesi veel. Vaata, kes ikka leiavad Nagu oma nagu lahenduse asja üle, et.
Õpetaja: No jah, jah, Ma ütlen, et valimistejõud on tugev ja tegelikult nende Tööriistadega on ka Ja kui hakkad kasutama. Mul on selles mõttes see on natuke nagu saatanast ka, et mul on nagu mingid nagu nupud, On nagu niivõrd nagu. Vaata, et käe sees,
Õpetaja: et ma hakkan ee näiteks brauseris kasutama neid shortcut E, mis on ja üks nendest on Kõige tappvam on see, et, ee,
Õpetaja: ee, intellisus on see, et kui sa kuskil koodireal selle kursus vaatad, liigutad niimoodi noortega üles. Alla. Veits on ju Kui sa paned Control V kaks, siis vabandust. Siis Ta selekteerib sõna
Õpetaja: eesmärgiga. Et Tahad, selle ümber kirjutada ja ära kustutada, aga Browser is on Control Kaks siis V on see et paned kinni
Õpetaja: ja see maksab nagu kätte nendes kohtades, kus on mingisugune pikk vorm. Täidad mingisugust. Lähed mingi lehele regad või? Mida iganes Kirjutad ära Ja eriti, kus on mingisugune suur tekstiboks. Kus Sa, nagu, noh, palju teksti Kirjutad üle mitme rea onju?
Õpetaja: Ja seal mul kipub olema niimoodi, et ongi, et sa juba kirjutad mingit asja. Vaatad siis mingi hetk, avastad Noh, mingi taipa või mingi sõna on vahelt vaja ära võtta. Lähed paar tõksu üles, Sest et, noh, hiilt ma vihkan. Vaata, paned vihkavad hiilt. Lähed sinna ülesse, valid selle, lähed selle sõna peale ja tahad seda selekteerida, nagu et oleks siniseks
Õpetaja: ja siis kustutada. Kirjutada Paned, vaatad kinni, aga. Okei. Noh, uuesti nüüd lahti teed. Ega need andmed enam ei ole Seal Lõpuks sa lihtsalt nagu käed käte sees on nagu Uus asi,
Õpetaja: aga ma ei tea. Võibolla see ka kõik hakkab muutuma. Võibolla varsti enam ei ole seda probleemi.
Õpetaja: Nii pikk jutt. Ee, Lähme, Edasi
Õpetaja: sain mina ka oma intellige lahti. Loodan, et teie saite ka
Õpetaja: nüüd. Esimene asi, mida võiks teha,
Õpetaja: mida mina võiks teha Praegult, on See, et mul on see, ee väikene demo haru, mis ma eile tegin. Aa, selle võiks siin ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Mis Ma pean selleks tegema, Seda saaks ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Ära minema. Miks
Õpetaja: Jaa, täpselt, et see oleks nagu see sama näide, et sa ei saa seda oksa saagida, mille peal. Sa istud või? See oleks mõistlik on, ju et, lähen peale ära
Õpetaja: Checkout. On siis see sõna millega, saab minna see On tegelikult Ee, siis ka. Kit is on selline sõna olemas. Taustal ongi Tegelikult, kui kui teha näiteks see siit lahti näete, see Kit I tööriist panna konsol,
Õpetaja: kui ma panen siit Clear all. Lihtsalt, et nagu oleks parem näidata. Mina olen praegult ee, Masteri peal, kui ma teen need Ee, minekorra feb seitsme peale Checkout.
Õpetaja: Siis taustal näete käivitus Niukene käsk.
Õpetaja: Tema nagu eriti pikalt. Tegelikult oleks saanud teha checkout, veb seitse ja Nagu lihtsamat, onju? Aga see ongi see, et te saate aru. Vaata, see, et te siin nuppe vajutate. See ei ole kuidagi ee, nagu Mingisugused lahendused,
Õpetaja: nagu ma mõtlen selles mõttes, et taustal toimetavad käsud. Ma saan selle sama asja. Ee, kas ta on seda lühendanud, või mitte, Vaata, mul pole õrna aimu. Ma vaatan korra. Ma lähen korra siit ära. Ütlen, lähen tagasi Masteri peale. On siin Masteri peal.
Õpetaja: Kui ma Võtan korra terminali lahti. Ee, teen terminalist. Näiteks mis on Windows keskkonnas. Kui ma nüüd siin panen selle sama käsu,
Õpetaja: see on pöördu programmi poole käsuga. Miinus C Kredential Helper. Ma ei tea, mis mis see ülejäänud mudru teeb. Vaata, on ju. Ee,
Õpetaja: oota. Mis mul selle nimi oli. Muidu oligi lihtsalt vep seitse. Kui ma nüüd vajutan. Enter
Õpetaja: siis taustal käivitus Kit I käsk programmis Näete, siin üleval muutus ka veb seitsmeks. Need nupud, mida te klõbistate, siis? Mis on Kitiga
Õpetaja: Need ei ole, see on lihtsalt. Need on tehtud Kasutaja User Interface Vaata kasutajal on tehtud mugavaks siin toimetada. Ee, kui te lähete nüüd arendusse tööle, siis te näete neid vanakooli vendasid, kes temalt kõik teevad Niimoodi
Õpetaja: nad ei tunnista neid nuppe nagu. Ja et selle asemel, et teha klikk, Klikk. Vaata nad nagu teevad termina lahti ja siis nad panevad oma,
Õpetaja: mis tasub ja ja hakkavad minema nagu. Ja nagu selles mõttes, nagu neid on vähem järjest.
Õpetaja: Aa, aga neid käsu. Ma kutsun neid käsurea Vendadeks Käsuleha, vennad.
Õpetaja: No, tavaliselt sa tegelt oskad igast asju teha. Ka. Vaata, nagu asi minevik.
Õpetaja: Ee, geograafilist asja polnud. Üldse Vaata, et ega See alguses oligi käsu Rea värk. Oligi see, et vaadata ära, see, et mis failid on ära kommititud ja mitte. No ma teen lihtsalt Kuskil mingi suvalise muudatuse. Näiteks siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, indeksfailist. Tegin paar tühja rida. Näete, siin Roheline tähendab alati uut.
Õpetaja: Tegin uued read, värvid ja mäng Ma hakkan nüüd tänasest alates jätma. Teile ka tegelikult. Ee. Natukene materjale, Mida kodus vaadata? Ee, pole rääkinud sellest, aga tegelikult. Ee, meil on Üks tasuline kursus, mida ammu poleme teinud. Online kursus, mis on teile täiesti kättesaadav ja saate teha. See on kõik olemas.
Õpetaja: Hakkab ühest kohast pihta on ju? Ee, eelkursuse projekt. Et tegelikult sealt samm sammult õpetab kõiki neid asju päris päris hästi
Õpetaja: ja mis ma nagu hakkangi tegema on see, et ma nüüd hakkan vaikselt viskama teile sinna Slacki Ee linke. Palun vaadake seda, et oda ja kolmandat vaata, et te saaksite Natukene nagu, ee, Vaadata mõningaid materjale süveneda. Mida me võibolla siin nii detailselt ei aruta? Aga Peaks teadma.
Õpetaja: Nii. Ee, tahtsin näidata siis. Noh, Kitstaatus. Noh, kitstaatus. Põhimõtteliselt annab mulle siis teada, et mis on hetkel seisja siin selles ee, kohalikus repos
Õpetaja: ja ta räägib, et brunch ise on Up to Date.
Õpetaja: Ja ta ütleb, et näed frontend indeks. Atml is on muudatused. Modify.
Õpetaja: No see ongi see sama fail Siin
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt seda sama asja. On nagu lihtsam nagu siit visuaalselt näha.
Õpetaja: Nagu selle tööriistaga. Vaata, onju? Aga Aga ütleme nii, et vana vanasti, kui ei olnud igasuguseid neid ee, kasutajaliidesid asju. Siis vennad panidki niimoodi. Aa ja. Ja mul on frontend Ind indeksis muudatused. Nüüd ma pean selle ära Kommitima on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, see käib niimoodi nii. Mm,
Õpetaja: kui teie. Teete siit comiiti lahti. Vaata, kas teil on mingi siin all.
Õpetaja: Ee, siit alt. Te näete kogu aeg muudatusi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja siis ongi mõned asjad, mida te peate teadma ka on see, et. Ee, millal te peate Tulema korra siia jälgima asju, et siit võibolla asjad ära visata. Ee, tee muudatused tagasi. Vaata, kui ma teen siia paar tühja rida seda Proovida siia ka
Õpetaja: paar tühja rida kuhugi.
Õpetaja: Kui mina praegu tulen siia peale
Õpetaja: ja vajutan niukest nuppu nagu Rolback siis see tähendab seda, et Mine Nagu viimase. Ee, ta põhimõtteliselt selles failis Taasta see fail niimoodi. Nagu ta viimati oli ära kommititud. Kui ta oli viimati ära kommititud Siis Seal ei olnud neid ühtlasi ridu. Ma tulen siia peale, vaid ta on näiteks. Ta küsib selle üle ka veel heaks. Jooks
Õpetaja: Wall Back lähevad muudatused ära.
Õpetaja: Teine variant on see, et kui ma oleks tahtnud seda tööd endale kuhugi panna, siis ma peaksin siia kirjutama mingi sõnumi, et ma muutsin indeks Atml faili. Ma ei tea, mis iganes ma siin tegin ja siis. Ära kommittima, on ju, et põhimõtteliselt need On need valikud?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis Nagu sind saab teha sellest kui tööriistast?
Õpetaja: Ee, no, ta on siin frontend I all
Õpetaja: ja see see tegelikult Nüüd tasubki keegi lahti teha.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin
Õpetaja: jah. Sealt tasub lahti teha, Aga mina Nüüd teen siis selle, et ma lähen sellelt Feb seitsmelt ära. Mida te kõigepealt peaksite tegema? Et üldse tulla järgima? Rääkisin meile, nagu vaatab, et peegeldus. Ta ei muuda mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: ta ainult põhimõtteliselt Kui siit sellest vaadata, Siit sellest visuaalsest asjast. Ta ainult peegeldab, et mis toimub. Remodis, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas tal praegu seda Feb seitset näeb. Ma vist Push. Isin selle ära. Vaata, on ju? Siis peab olema onju?
Õpetaja: Aa, mis mina teen nüüd, on see, et Ma lähen Masteri peale. Korra teen checkout.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on niimoodi. Vot nüüd on see punase joone värk. Näete seal tahvli peal, mäletate? Ükski Muudatus, pilve
Õpetaja: ja vastupidi, ei toimu ilma nuppe klõbistamata.
Õpetaja: Aa, kui mina kustutan ära. Näiteks praegult. Ahaa, teeme ühe seadistuse ka Ära Näete seda, mis kogu aeg näitab. See on jube tüütu elukas. Nagu Tegelikult, tahaks kogu aeg näha siin all lokalite remonti. See tekitab segadust, kui te Teete selle harumajanduse siit ülevalt lahti ja võtate hammasratta,
Õpetaja: Siis siin on olemas Show actions. Aa, recent Brunches. Mina võtaks selle. Ära.
Õpetaja: Seal ei ole üldse mitte mingit point I. Ja ma ütlen, et ta läheb ilmselt eest ära. Siis kui nüüd teist korda lahti teha ei läinud Nii, ära
Õpetaja: aa. No. Siia. Peab konkreetselt vajutama. Ma arvan selle linnukese peale
Õpetaja: mingi täheks ka selle võime ka ära võtta.
Õpetaja: Pole nüüd täiega niikuinii selles projektis.
Õpetaja: Nii et, ee, niimoodi. Niimoodi on palju puhtam. See riset hakkab kogu aeg ette hüppama. Ma vihkan seda niipea, kui sa fiatuuri tõid. Mul on nagu seda, et nagu
Õpetaja: ülivastik, nagu kogu aeg. Ma tahan vajutada siia. Ta hüppab peale. Ma ei tea, miks see, Mille jaoks see vajalik on? Nagu, kui palju neid harusid peab inimesel olema? Nagu et seda vaadata. Ta nagu näitab, et kui sa oled kuidagi kolanud või? Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: Mõttetu jama. Aa, mina kustutan ära. Ee, ütlen selle. Vaadake, mis toimub. Ma ütlen, Feb seitsme peal, ma ütlen.
Õpetaja: Ta nüüd kustutas selle siit Aa lokali alt ära. Aga kus ta seda ära ei kustutanud?
Õpetaja: Pilvest siin paremal pool hüppas lahti, Niukene Aken, mis ütleb, et. Kuule. Aga et sa kustutasid ära? Ee, veb seitsme. Kas sa tahad ka delitada? Track Branch
Õpetaja: Remote Origin Track Branch, See tähendab alati lihtsalt
Õpetaja: nagu nende serverit. Ma saan mugavalt siit ka vajutada. Nuppu praegult. Või? Noh, kui mul see läheb, linnuke läheb mööda, Ma Saan seda alati käsitsi teha. On ju, et siit ülevalt saab neid asju teha, kustutada ja teha, aga siit alt saab ka valida Samad valikud sealt. Siit tuleb parema klõpsuga.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt nagu jutt käib nendest samadest asjadest, et lihtsalt nad on enne niimoodi, et mitmes kohas saad ka enda nagu, ee, toimetada nende asjadega.
Õpetaja: No kui läks üldse. Kui üldse mingi sõnum läheb mööda. Näete, siin üleval on see kellukene siin Siit saab veel, Va neid samu sõnumeid vaadata? Mis on eelnevalt mööda läinud?
Õpetaja: Ma võin siin ka vajutada, delete Ja vaadake, mis ta nüüd teeb. Ta küsib üle.
Õpetaja: Kas sa tahad seda kustutada? Kui ma tegin seda Local Branche I käest, Ta ei küsinud üle
Õpetaja: sest et see ei ole ohtlik aga kõik, mis on pilves ta on iga kord. See on kõige ohtlikum asi üldse. Vaata, on see, et vaata ühine projekt,
Õpetaja: et siin on nagu sisse ehitatud teatud Safety Meziure Id. Vaata, et äkki, ma kogemata vajutasin, et kustuta ära ka mingi keegi on Mingi kuu aega, võibolla rämedalt tööd teinud. Ee, on oma haru pilve push Inud oma arvutis tal näiteks seda. Mingil põhjusel enam pole, onju?
Õpetaja: Tulen mina mingisugune. Tahan mingit oma haru. Praegult on siin mingid lihtsad numbrid. Aga kujutage ette, päris arenduses on mingi ee,
Õpetaja: Ee, mingi näiteks Feb. Üheksa, kuus, Ee kaheksa,
Õpetaja: V, kaheksa, üheksa, kaheksa, kuus. Numbrid hakkavad olema nagu samapidi. Kui ma läheks, hakkaksin kustutama kellegi teise haru vähemalt. Vähemalt ühe korra tuleb mulle see nagu ette. Ja kui seal vajutad, Yes, siis sa oled ise loll. Vaata,
Õpetaja: midagi ei ole teha, kes see kunagi külas. See on üks ettevõte kes on ka siin samas lähedal. Nad on ka meie õpilased. Seal on päris mitmeid valiteid. Täna töötab.
Õpetaja: Ee, käisime. Neil. Tegime ühe ekstra koolituse ja seal oli mingi developer oli. Ja siis ta rääkis, et ta suutis oma karjääri alguses Ee, lasta õhku nelja inimese kuu töö
Õpetaja: niimoodi, et ei saanudki taastada,
Õpetaja: kui ta oli liit Developer seal hiljem. Nii, et näed, ilmselt ta Sai veel teise võimaluse.
Õpetaja: Aga ma arvan, et Nad mõtlesid küll juba et kas see vend on ikka nagu, ee, vajalik.
Õpetaja: Noh, nalja ta selle üle viskas, eks? See oligi naljakas. Pärast
Õpetaja: Paljud asjad on niimoodi, et alguses on väga valus, aga, noh, kunagi hiljem juba teist nagu Naerat.
Õpetaja: Ee, no nii, ee. Kustutan mina selle Sweb seitsme ära. Nüüd on nagu, see et see on nagu hea näide. Vaata, et ma Kustutasin selle. Ta teeb seda praegu. Ta ei ole jõudnud seda siin ära teha.
Õpetaja: Aga mida ma nüüd tahan? Nagu teile jälle näidata, on See, et kohe, kui ta ütleb, et see on tehtud,
Õpetaja: See teeb seitse pilvest.
Õpetaja: Kuuskümmend.
Õpetaja: Minul kadus ta siit remoodi alt, ära, sest et Ta nüüd teab, et seda ei ole seal. Kuidas on lood teil remoodi ajal?
Õpetaja: Mis siin, on on ikka sellepärast, et see peegeldus ei ole reaalajas.
Õpetaja: Ta ei käi kogu aeg. Ei, käi kogu aeg vaatamas, et. Kuule, mis seal pilves on? Mis seal pilves on? Mis seal Pilves on? Kuidas ta siit ära kaob, onju? Ta ei muuda mitte midagi. Ma ütlen, et ega See on lihtsalt peegeldus, see kogu see Asi lihtsalt siis oskab neid asju vaadata selle peegeldusega. Kui te, siis ta läheb
Õpetaja: nii. Aga nüüd on ikka teil see, et teil vist Master on Grummi võrra maast. Teil kohalik Master on? Ei,
Õpetaja: jah,
Õpetaja: ee, Siis Masteriga. Te peaksite nüüd tegema niimoodi, et teete kliki selle peale Ja vajutate. Ma korra panen selle konsooli siit lahti, et saaks nüüd käske. Vaadata. Ee, kui te lähete nüüd selle peale ja panete update,
Õpetaja: Siis Ta teeb taustal Fetchi ja Pull I. See pull on nüüd päris käsk. Vaata, nagu et sinul on töö seal. See lokal on Teie Work Working Nagu director. Siin saab tööd teha
Õpetaja: kõik need, mis te olete Checkout I teinud. Teil on ainult Mastersil, on ju
Õpetaja: Ee, et see tähendab juba päris failide muudatusi. See teie selles tööharus,
Õpetaja: kui teha update, peaks vist tegema kaks käskonna. Tegin Fetch I
Õpetaja: ja okei, No ta tegi selle mingi ühe käsuga ära. Aga põhimõtteliselt ta tegi pulli ka siia otsa.
Õpetaja: See on vaja Fancy. Lihtsalt pruun. Jah,
Õpetaja: mina isiklikult seda käsku pruuni ei tea, nagu. Noh, ma teangi, et ta umbes midagi taolist teeb. Vaata aga see on ka mingi bulli versioon,
Õpetaja: Aga tõeliselt Jätke mõelda. Pushen poll. Pushen pool.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt. Siin on ee oma nimi. Lihtsalt selle ma ei tea Vanasti oli isegi Bull kusjuures ei olnud. Update
Õpetaja: on kuidagi teinud seal
Õpetaja: pruun vä, Võibolla.
Õpetaja: Noh, saab kohe Kohe saab vaadata, nagu siin saab. Ee, vaatame, teeme. Teeme minu arvutis teen. Vaata, onju. Teil vaadake praegu. Aa, siin on Skill Id. Mis on Skill? Id on Aa, Skill on siis juhend? Tegelikult, ee, Mida saab siuke Taaskasutatav juhend.
Õpetaja: Minul on Skill Aa loo uus õppematerjal loo uus Beginnerfriendi õppematerjal eesti keeles ja salvesta
Õpetaja: ee, siis ta räägib Natukene visuaalsema poole. Vaata, onju, et kuidas ta näitab, et
Õpetaja: küsi. Ee, küsi teema. Küsi kasutajalt. Millisel teemal soovid? Uut materjali luua näiteks Cc Struktuur Ja Kasutamine, oota vastust ennem. Kui jätkad kontrolli olemasolevaid materjale. Vaata, kas juba on olemas Samal teemal materjal, äkki siis lisa mingi uus teema kuskile alla.
Õpetaja: Arvesta vestluse konteksti. Kui me oleme siin midagi juba jäppinud, siis ta teab, ka, mida me Räägime. Koostöömaterjal. Materjal peab sisaldama Selge, pealkirja Eesti keeles.
Õpetaja: Ee, lühikene sissejuhata sissejuhatus. Visuaalsed skeemid, koodinäited, päriselu, analoogiad. Kokkuvõtte tabelina järgmised sammud stiilireeglid eesti keeles. Bla bla bla saate aru, See on juhend.
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt fail mis on sihukes kaustas nagu Cloud Skills
Õpetaja: loo Skill luo. Uus õppematerjal Skill Niukene asi See on Cloud I Võlur. Nüüd ma teen Cloud I lahti. Ütlen Cloud.
Õpetaja: Teen Cloud I. Wsl lahti. Tal on absoluutselt kõikvõimalikud head asjad olemas. Ee, panen kaldkriips.
Õpetaja: Ja mina olen oma skill Id kõik meelega nimetanud. Niimoodi sõnaga Skill. Noh, tegelikult nagu tava. On pigem, see et sa Ütled kohe, et uus õppematerjal on nagu selle skill I nimi. Aga mulle meeldib, et kui mul on palju enda tehtud skill E, siis Ma leian nad kiirelt niimoodi ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ja siin ma juba saan otsida.
Õpetaja: Mina tahan siit. Loovusõppematerjal näitab siin. Mul ka. Vaata, et ee, mis Ta, mis ta nagu teeb. Seda Sama Skill Id töötavad, on see, et iga kord, kui sa Cloud I Avad vaata, siis ta loeb, Loeb sisse kõik Skill Id mitte sisulise poole pealt, vaid need nimed ja Description Id.
Õpetaja: Ja kui sa temaga Chat Id ja vestled seal midagi. Siis Sa võid isegi öelda talle loo uus õppematerjal. Sa tegelikult Descriptionist juba näed, Vaata, et
Õpetaja: tal on tegelikult Niukene skill, kus on Mainitud sõna loo uus õppematerjal. Ilmselt see võiks kuidagi teda aidata. Ta oskab ise ka seda käivitada, Aga nii niimoodi lihtsana. Niimoodi saab, nagu Kindlalt ma käivitan. Skill I loo Uus õppematerjal. See on vaatamise koht
Õpetaja: koos õppematerjal. Nüüd ta peaks küsima, mis teemal ma küsin, nagu mida teeb Jit rrune.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: vaata, on olemas õppematerjalid. Seal pole praegu mitte midagi. Ee, siin toks kaustas vist ei ole, veel ei ole, siis Ta peab need kaustad tegema.
Õpetaja: Olemasolev materjal. Samal teemal ei ole Kaust. Hetkel puudub loen. Loon selle. Ka Koostan materjalide eemal. Kid, pruun, käsitlen Kitbruun käsku, aga konteksti. Miks see vajalik on? Kuidas on seotud, sellega et see oleks mõistetav noh?
Õpetaja: Noh, see, nüüd, on nagu see mis, Ma lubasin kohe alguses. Vaata, et alguses me kasutame seda. Aid ja Cloud Code. Kui ee, õpe isiklik õpetaja. Vaata,
Õpetaja: see on mingi küsimus?
Õpetaja: Küsin väga. Skill on olemas
Õpetaja: Pea ise pikalt jääpima, Vaata, onju? Ta teab, mismoodi ta teeb. Igas alati samas formaadis. Ta paneb sinna selle, Ma lisan sinna projekti juurde.
Õpetaja: Igaveseks Jääb alles,
Õpetaja: Kui ma päriselt tegelikult teen. Aa ise olen teinud arendust. Aa siis ma need hobiprojektid ja Mitu hobiprojektid? Ee, siis ma olen samamoodi teinud niimoodi et ma tegelikult, kui ta genereerin mingisugust kooli ja asja mulle, minu jaoks on see nagu mingi uus asi. Vaatan, et. Okei, See on mingi mingi uus asi. Ma pole varem näinud seda. Siis ma lihtsalt ütlen. Kuule, tee mulle õppematerjal
Õpetaja: sellel teemal. Vaata, onju, Ta teeb mulle materjali, Ta paneb nime, Ta toob näite, teeb selgitused ja nii edasi. Vaatan selle ühe korra läbi. Ta jääb sinna teooriamaterjalide alla mulle Teinekord, siis hiljem, kui ma jälle põrkan selle vastu ja ma mäletan, et.
Õpetaja: Oot, oot, kurat, Seda, mis see täpselt tegigi, siis ma. Ma mäletan juba vähemalt, et mul on olemas õppematerjal selle kohta või ma korra vaatan, kas ma nagu Olen midagi selle kohta teinud. Vähemalt tuletan kiirelt endale Meelde
Õpetaja: Ee, mis see nagu on on ju?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ta ütleb, et see on tehtud siis, kui see klikkida peale toks kaustale.
Õpetaja: Ee vahel on, niimoodi et ta tekitab uusi faile juurde. Ee, mida kohe intellige ei Näita
Õpetaja: Intelligence. Nagu reaktiivsus on Vahel natukene kannatab, et ta ei saa aru, et sul midagi uut on. Siin taustas üldse, onju, kui teha nagu see projekti peale parem klõps Ja, panna. Noh, see on vaatamise kohta.
Õpetaja: Siis ta nagu kiirelt vaatab üle, et kuule, kõik, mis mul siin taustas, on tuli.
Õpetaja: Ee, tasub vaadata seda nagu selles Preview vaatajas. Mis see on?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis kustutab hüljatud objektid. Need on failide sisud, kommit. Id Kaustapuud, millele enam miski ei viita.
Õpetaja: Ei mingi. Ma ei viitsi seda lugeda isegi praegu et see ei olnud eesmärk, aga saate mõttest aru. Vaata, et ta tegelikult räägib nüüd kõik lahti.
Õpetaja: Et mis asi see on ja mis sind see nagu huvitaks
Õpetaja: nüüd mis tegelikult, Ee, on võibolla parem. Variant on see. Vaata, et see on kõik Md Fail. Vaata, Md Faili mõte on see, et selles kirjaviisis on võimalik tegelikult teha kirja selliselt, et ta on nagu. Näiteks. Näete neid. Hashtag E. See on suur pealkiri Väiksem pealkiri. Veel väiksem pealkiri.
Õpetaja: Kui Sa tuled siia, vaatad
Õpetaja: suur pealkiri. Väiksem pealkiri. Veel väiksem pealkiri. Ja kas koodiplokid? Ee, ja nii edasi, et neid on võimalik, nagu defineerida, Miks Sellepärast, et see annab tegelikult teksti kuju struktuuri?
Õpetaja: See siin on koodiblokk. Siin sees on kood.
Õpetaja: See siin on pealkiri. See on siin Tähtsam punkt. See on vähem tähtsam punkt ja nii edasi. Ee, et kõik, kuidas Cloudil endal taustal tema endale sisse ehitatud failid töötavad samamoodi selle Md Mark Down Formaadis.
Õpetaja: See on väga hea formaat Sellepärast, et seda on kirjaviisis võimalik. On ee, väga palju ära teha. Tavatekstiga
Õpetaja: see Vahet pole, Vaata, kus sa seda kirjutad. Mismoodi kirjutad? Erinevad keskkonnad võivad visualiseerida seda natukene nagu erinevalt. Aga see mõte on sama. Et päeva, Lõpuks ta tegelikult on selline tekst
Õpetaja: ja sellist teksti. Noh, see on tekst. Näete selline tekst? Seda on võimalik kuhu iganes nagu panna,
Õpetaja: see Siin on koodiblokk. Nagu põhimõtteliselt. Ee, enne pruuni Mingisugune näide. Otsime kus sama sama näide visualiseeritult
Õpetaja: on? See koht siin? Koodiblokk Saad kohe Copida Näiteks mugav.
Õpetaja: Aga mis on muidugi parem. Ja tänapäeval, mida? Nagu teha on üldse Hoopis Tegelikult see lõppematerjal võiks öelda, et teeme siis Html Fail.
Õpetaja: Võibolla isegi teie interaktiivne Html Fail.
Õpetaja: Et, Ee, see sama asi on lihtsalt siis Browseriga avatav ja ta on märksa silmasõbralikum, veelgi, parem
Õpetaja: Ee, et, Noh, võime öelda, võin öelda talle, et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: tees sellest. Ee, sellest ka üks interaktiivne, Ee, Html.
Õpetaja: Ee, stiilis õppematerjal.
Õpetaja: Noh, vaatame Mis Ta teeb
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: samal ajal, kui tema seda teeb, siis aa. Räägin siin teistest asjadest. Aa, näete, siin on Niukene asi nagu Unversion Files.
Õpetaja: Tema värv on punane.
Õpetaja: Mida see tähendab praegult? Seda, et ee, kit. Ee Niiöelda see versioneerimine teda ei kuidagi ei jälgi ja see Pilve ka ei lähe. Seda ei ole võimalik Push Ida kuidagi pilve.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ta selle faili tekitas. Ma ei pannud tähele, kas ta Praegu küsis või mitte, aga põhimõtteliselt, kui ise lood uue faili näiteks New File, siis ta alati küsib. Vaata, et kas sa tahad, et Ta on nagu osa nagu projektist ja ta on versioneeritud. Niiöelda näete siin see sama.
Õpetaja: Kui see aken läheb mööda, siis on mitu varianti Üks variant on, et tuled siia peale
Õpetaja: selle faili peale ja otsin nagu Kitty Ee, Niiöelda käsud ja kit ad
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd panen selle Ad I, Siis ta muutub roheliseks, sest et see on täiesti tutikas. Uus fail,
Õpetaja: mis on ilmselt, mis on jälgitav.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta jälgib seda. Nüüd on võimalik kommit ida. Seda faili. Kas kui tuhat korda vaatab mingeid muudatusi ta tema kohta on Ajalugu
Õpetaja: pigem defineerida.
Õpetaja: Mkm,
Õpetaja: see on see. Vaata, näete seda ma nüüd korra? Ma tulen korra siia samma kohta tagasi ja ma panen siia. Ee, mis tegelikult ei tähenda Failide liiti, vaid see tähendab, seda, et, ee, ei jälgi.
Õpetaja: Ta läheb tagasi sinna või? Oi, kas tõesti.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei. Tähendab, siiski deliit.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Aga vaata, ta tuli tagasi ja ta küsib. Vaata seda akent. Ad file to kit. See ongi see, et lisa jälgimisse või mitte. Vaata, on ju Ma panen korra praegu siin siiski, Cancel. Nüüd ma küsin, mis vahe on sellel ja sellel värvil.
Õpetaja: Jaa, see on nagu vaevumärgatav, Aga Siin on niimoodi, et Kit I juures käib. Niukene Fail nagu Kittignoor.
Õpetaja: Ja just sellest, kuidas su nimi oli,
Õpetaja: millest Jaanus praegult nagu rääkis. Vaata, et et nagu te küsite, kas see vaikimis ei ole Lihtsalt nii et kõik asjad, mis on Ignooris. Vaata, need ei lähe Niiöelda automaatselt lähevad Ei ole. Iga faili puhul peab siiski tegelikult eraldi ütlema. Vaata, et versioneeri seda,
Õpetaja: aga see kittignoor on nüüd väga tähtis tööriist.
Õpetaja: Ee, see sama punktidea kaust. Tegelikult ei peaks olema osa projektist. Minul on mingisugused minu säted ja asjad ja mis mina teen ja Kõik see info on seal selles kaustas Kuidagi olemas
Õpetaja: see ei ole. Meil on meeskonnas. Ütleme, meil on ettevõttes sada arendajat, kes seal projektis töötavad neil. Kõigil on oma säted ja asjad neil on oma andmebaasi ühendused, võibolla mingi asjadega ja nii edasi. See ei ole osa projektist Ja see ongi see klieting. Noor On võimalus, kus me saame ära defineerida. Kus me ütleme, et ära seda mitte mingil juhul
Õpetaja: projekti kaasa paneb Seda ei ole võimal. Seda me ei personeeri. Seda. Me ei jälgi
Õpetaja: Selle koha. Ei saa mitte midagi teha. Ta ei lähe ka pilve, mitte mingi valemiga.
Õpetaja: Ja näiteks siin ongi näha. Näete, see sama punktideo ka Just
Õpetaja: see viitabki tegelikult sellele taustale siin. Ma kustutan selle siit ära.
Õpetaja: Ja võibolla teen korra siin. Refresh ma ei tea, kuidas sellega on.
Õpetaja: Näete, see kaust on nüüd tavalist värvi, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui Ma tulen siia kausta peale ja panen siia, et. Ee, kit ad to keep ignor.
Õpetaja: Siis ta tuli siia tagasi.
Õpetaja: Noh, alla tuli nagu Ta paneb järjest neid saate mõttes aru.
Õpetaja: See siin võimaldab põhimõtteliselt Siis nagu
Õpetaja: ära defineerida seda, Vaata, mis on projekti osa ja mitte ja Seda on tähtis teada. Meil saavad olla meil näiteks hiljem. Kasutame ühte niukest lahendust mis Koni ise geneerib meile tegelikult koodifaile,
Õpetaja: aga me tegelikult ei soovi, et nad lähevad kittli. Sellepärast, et need automaatselt iga kord serveri käivitamisel genereeritakse uuesti ja uuesti. Ehk kui meie lahendus läheb nii öelda serverisse, siis server teeb täpipealt seda. Sama. Ta genereerib nad ise
Õpetaja: automaatselt. Neil ei ole vaja nii öelda. Kui me jõuame sinnamaani, siis Seal on näiteks üks kaust, mis me ühel hetkel tahame kindlalt öelda, et ära seda manti
Õpetaja: kaasa nagu Võta
Õpetaja: kittignoorid. On Märksa nagu mahukamad. Et siin, on nagu igast juba, et on juba teada vaikimisi, et mingi veeskoodi asju pole vaja. Asju Pole vaja. Tavaliselt need kittignoorid on Nagu märksa vaikimis. Kui sa teed uue Kit I. Selle projektina, on juba märksa mahukamad.
Õpetaja: Ilmselt. No kuskil ongi ka, et siin on mul Ka kittig. Noor niiöelda Backendi all. Näete,
Õpetaja: backendi all on eraldi kit. Ignor ta sellega ka arvestab. Ja frontend. I all peaks olema ka Kit Ignor Vist jää peast enam. Näe, Kit Ignor. Siin on mingi front I. Asjad, mida pole vaja. Näiteks see sama Note modul. See ei ole osa projektist.
Õpetaja: Seal ehitatakse sealt failid ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, vaatame, kuidas Ee, Kas meie vend on ka siin ära teinud? Ee, vaatame, mis meil on? Siin?
Õpetaja: Kas soovid, et lisan selle lingi ka viitena?
Õpetaja: Kus sa selle faili siis tegid?
Õpetaja: Oi, ta tegi mingi artifakti.
Õpetaja: Tüüp. Tüüp tegi nagu põmm. Palun väga, nagu paneme kogu maailmale nähtavaks Ee Prügikasti tühjendamine.
Õpetaja: Näete lähtes. Ta Siin on mingi interaktiivne õppematerjal, saate aru,
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma tegelikult nii ei mõelnud. Nagu vot olekski pidanud. Nagu interaktiivne ka. Ma ei tea, mis siin saab klikkida või midagi teha ka, Või
Õpetaja: No ütleme olenemismaterjaliga teed, aga saate aru, et see vist on nagu kohati on natukene mõnusam materjal.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt kui ma oleks saanud üldse projektiks. Vaata, ma ütlen. Aa, ära lisa linki. Ma ütlen, Ee. Lisa siia. Kohalik.
Õpetaja: Vaata, on veel fail.
Õpetaja: The Möll.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, saab aru. Ütleb, et pole olemas siukest asja. Vaata, möll taiba.
Õpetaja: Näed nüüd ta. Sa salvestab sellise kausta juurde.
Õpetaja: On siin Kip. Pruun Html
Õpetaja: Teen selle lahti, See on nüüd Html kood. Mida? Me hakkame kohe kohe vaatama koos stiilide ja kõigega. Aga kui
Õpetaja: Et Millega sa lahti teha vaatasin, siis Ee saab öelda ka, et. Kuule, tee sealt browser is lahti. Nagu on sama fail,
Õpetaja: eks?
Õpetaja: Kolm ei ole katki. Vä Okei, prü midagi on puudu mingi tähetugi
Õpetaja: No siis. Saaks öelda, et Kuule, prügikasti tähendamine.
Õpetaja: See oli ennem selle
Õpetaja: Ee Cloud Installiga ka hakkas viskama neid ee asju ja siis ise. Ta pakkus selle lahenduseks, et
Õpetaja: Microsofti poest välja.
Õpetaja: Aga tegelikult fondi vahetamise aitab
Õpetaja: Jah, Ta tegi mingi erilise fondiga ka, Vaata, ta panigi. Nagu. No ütleme niimoodi, et vaata. Selle jaoks juba oleks mõistlik teha tegelikult. Eraldi skill. Vaata. Kus, sa selgitadki ära. Vaata Palun arvesta sellega, et testid Ad kasutatakse fonti. Vaata, onju Kasutatakse toonae, bla, bla, bla, blabla,
Õpetaja: et. Ee. Kui ma. Nagu igapäevaselt sooviksin niukseid, asju. Siis mul oleks selle kohta skill,
Õpetaja: nagu. Mis? Nagu Ütleks, et ma soovingi seda sellises formaadis ja kirjeldusega, aga seda lihtsalt see ee, Cloud Code. Nagu see tööriist.
Õpetaja: Ee, tema näiteks ütles, et see Boris kasutabki nagu. Ja paljud juba kirjutavad, et nad tegelikult Md faile väga ei eelistagi. Aga ma ütlen, et tegelikult kõik juhised ja asjad need on niikuinii. Need peavad olema Md lihtsalt sellepärast, et nad on paganama Lihtsalt, ee, nendele. Ai dele.
Õpetaja: Nad saavad väga, väga hästi aru Kõigest struktuurist tähtsusest poodiblokkidest. Kõigest, et selles mõttes on nagu mõnus, on niimoodi, No eks me võime vaadata, kas me teeme siis mingeid selliseid asju koolituse jooksul või mitte, aga aga lihtsalt võimalused,
Õpetaja: nagu ma mul oli Tütar pidi õppima, mis asi on jõuõlg? Mingi ja keemiat tegi ka Vahepeal. Mul oli nagu see et ise, aita. Vaata mulle, nagu kohe Aitan Do
Õpetaja: Pildi pildid Facebookist.
Õpetaja: Palun tee mul interaktiivne Õppematerjal. Algajasõbralik. Kasutasid sama skill I
Õpetaja: alguses. Tegin Md Vaata sain nagu paika nagu enamvähem. Mis see sisu võiks olla? Ise süübisin ka sellesse, et Üritasin siis aru saada, kuidas jõuvõlg käib. Mu naine kusjuures aastaid rääkis, et see On ainuke asi, mida ma tean, on jõuvõlg. Vaata onju füüsikast, et ta on meelde jäänud
Õpetaja: ja siis tütar öelda, et Kuule, ema sa Rääkisid kogu aeg jõuvõlga. Nagu sisevari.
Õpetaja: Ei tea Midagi ikka pidin mina õpetama. Ma olen ise õpetanud ja saimegi. Tegin mingid interaktiivsed asjad said seal mingeid asju muuta, teha ja kohe sai selgeks nagu, ee, tšilli pilli.
Õpetaja: Nii, Noh, no, mina võin ära kommittida. Need või ma kõigepealt Ütlengi, et nagu või Noh, mingi. Sõnum võiks olla Vaata, et ma ei tea. Lisa, siin
Õpetaja: kontrollide ühik toob ette need ee näited ee, Mis siin justkui on,
Õpetaja: mis ta ei tunne. Aa, kui saab teha parema klõpsuga kit Ad,
Õpetaja: siis tegelikult saab niimoodi ka, et ma saan Nad tilida siia alla.
Õpetaja: Mis sama asi taustal?
Õpetaja: No vahet pole, kuidas ei ole. Ma vaatan, kuidas ma julgen proovida Proovin Rolback I
Õpetaja: Ee Kas Rolback kaotab selle täielikult ära?
Õpetaja: See peaks siis olema see, et kui kogemata lisad midagi, ma vanasti ei teadnud seda, kuidas seda teha, Kui sa kogemata vajutad Kit ad mingi asjale, saad aru, et oi, oi, oi, see on mingi jama. Ja ma ei taha seda ja Mida iganes siis Roll Back. Esialgu paneb ta lihtsalt Unversion Faili. Alla
Õpetaja: ei kustuta ära. Deliit on ikka deliit.
Õpetaja: Noh, selle õppesime Hardware, aga Control. See et aitas nagu By the way Et, isegi kui siin on mingid failid mida, mida, nagu selles mõttes sina kite Ei jälgi versioneerimisega, siis on sisse ehitatud ka Niukene funktsionaalsus nagu Local History.
Õpetaja: Kui ma võtan näiteks selle sama mida ma ennem millega, me mässime, ennem see indeks saate, on meil
Õpetaja: tänaseks. Ma olen juba taastanud. Vaata, siin olid mingid tühjad read ja asjad oli nii
Õpetaja: kui teha, näiteks siin Lihtsalt, ee, klõps ja Local History Show. History
Õpetaja: Ta näitab ka. Oota, kui ma leian kuskilt siit. Ta Ta leiab erinevaid hetki. Vaata, kus Ma olen siin toimetanud, et sa saad Tegelikult, et sa kustutad kogemata mingeid faile asju ära.
Õpetaja: Sa saad tegelikult, kuidas veel isegi saab teha, on see, et sa saad kogu kataloogi mõttes. Tuled kogu projekti peale. Ütled, et Kuule, näita mulle Ee Local History
Õpetaja: ja nüüd hakkab failide kaupa seda kuidagi näitama ka täpselt ei mäleta, kuidas seda saab. Kuidagi saab veel
Õpetaja: ka. Näed, siin all on failid. Näete,
Õpetaja: ma ei ole nii palju muudatusi teinud, et see on. Ka see on. See on nagu see viimane Ee päästerõngas, kuhu kogemata kutsutud mingid asjad, ära ee Ja mis ei ole versioneerimises,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult ta tööriist ise aitab ka nagu jälgida.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle ma ütlen. Noh, see on see Ultimate nagu See on nagu
Õpetaja: okei Japa jäpa. Kas te. Kas. Aa, Ma ütlesin, et tehke siis Ja siis tehke selle masteri peal update,
Õpetaja: siis te Olete täpselt samal joone ajal nagu mina Ja teil peaks olema Niuke. Tere, maailm.
Õpetaja: Jah, noh,
Õpetaja: rahmatikud võivad, aga kas sa ühiselt oled vaadanud
Õpetaja: Palju on Ka see teine koht
Õpetaja: on siin.
Õpetaja: Proovime.
Õpetaja: Jaa,
Õpetaja: ee, kiiremata
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga
Õpetaja: jah.
Õpetaja: Aa, käepärast. Aga ma praegu ise.
Õpetaja: Aa, rekordi, kui peaks pausile panema. Väga hea,
Õpetaja: lülikas.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Väga hea mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ta ei tee ju mitte midagi halba.
Õpetaja: Ee, sa mõtled seda. Seda Siin on kaks Variantset, Jah,
Õpetaja: Kas sa valed või Ei, ole?
Õpetaja: Aa, nii
Õpetaja: algus. Mulle maksavad Selge, Mõnus oli olemas
Õpetaja: autoriseerida.
Õpetaja: Mm, aga ma ei tea, kas Okei,
Õpetaja: loomisõneliseks. Sealt jaoks alguseks.
Õpetaja: Mina olen küll Kristallis.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis minna sama seal ja. Ja mina ei pea seda ühendust tegema
Õpetaja: Laadressil nii
Õpetaja: anda kindlasti.
Õpetaja: Noh, küsida kuus
Õpetaja: programmile ja siis, ee, kirjutada mugavalt.
Õpetaja: Jah, ee, põhimõtteliselt see on jah. See on nagu kõik mugavad kõik asjad, onju
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt nagu arendaja. Absoluutselt kõik asjad nagu ära majandada.
Õpetaja: Kus lõputu töötab Päris paljusid keemi ja talle tegelikult on mõeldud eelkõige ikkagi, Ee,
Õpetaja: Ta on jah, nagu nende niukene. Ee, piirangud. Päris niisugune. Erinevad tooted, et see, ee. Ettevõte ise toode.
Õpetaja: Aga Ta on nüüd natuke
Õpetaja: ta on selles mõttes kaduline. Aga tasuta on kolmkümmend päeva Ja siis mina jagan kursusele raamatid, millega on pool aastat.
Õpetaja: See ei selles mõttes,
Õpetaja: No
Õpetaja: Aa, saab hoopis seoses Nii, okei, okei,
Õpetaja: on. See
Õpetaja: ei ole ka.
Õpetaja: Mis kolida?
Õpetaja: Mhmh, proovida.
Õpetaja: Jah, see viis klienti.
Õpetaja: Vabandust,
Õpetaja: nii, igal ajal on riist.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: mhmh, Ee. Need tulukesed jäävad tulema, vaata kui ta nagu ei vähene. Vaata nupukene Vaata, mis näiteks käivad.
Õpetaja: Aitäh väikse riigile Selle info sain ma eile õppinud.
Õpetaja: Täna me saime Täna Me proovisime. Mul oli üks mõte. Vaata, kuidas äkki saab hästi kiirelt. Vaata, mis See töötab, sest et sul on oma arvuti.
Õpetaja: Töötab sellega ka. Oli vaja. Ära proovida, ja nii et väga Hea, Mul on väga hea meel, et see töötab
Õpetaja: ikkagi tegelikult ee, lihtsamaks.
Õpetaja: Tõesti mingi asju pusida ja teha Aga suurem väärtus. Ma olen teemad
Õpetaja: võimalik hinnangul
Õpetaja: Ee, kaamera,
Õpetaja: Just
Õpetaja: jõudu
Õpetaja: vaba.
Õpetaja: Väga, väga kaugele
Õpetaja: Või kui?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: jälle keskastuspoliitiliselt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on just ma vaatangi, et kõik on nagu
Õpetaja: eraaiad, on kinni pandud Vast väga mujal.
Õpetaja: Aga umbes nii nagu seal. Sealt puidust väraved on? Teab. Eksole? Lähed sealt lihtsalt? Võibolla need väravad lahti. Lähed seekord läbi Vajad on?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: see oli keeruline. On see probleem Üheksa?
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt ise ka kõikides hariduses.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta on sellest automaatselt neljakümne miljoni minutiga ära,
Õpetaja: Nüüd mul on siin midagi täpselt.
Õpetaja: Ja minu arust viimase etapi, Aga kohe oli
Õpetaja: teisega.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea,
Õpetaja: aga ma võiks ee, kohe ise ära mõjutanud.
Õpetaja: Vaata ja odavad niimoodi
Õpetaja: konkreetselt
Õpetaja: nii palju teha.
Õpetaja: Millest vaatad?
Õpetaja: Vana sõnu.
Õpetaja: Ee, Windows. Soorima vanast arvutist. Kõik tõsta ühe klikiga üks Muude arvuks
Õpetaja: Laud küsis. Vot see nagu sa katsed. Ma panin siia terminali ja siis ma vajutan ise Või inimene
Õpetaja: siuke asi veel, kui ma selle Cloud I Siin panin. Mul ennem oli selles ee terminalid väljapoole.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma neid setting uid vaatasin. Korra. Ma ei osanud, nagu talle peaks panema. Muidugi,
Õpetaja: siin on nagu. See. Vaata, et taustavaate saab aru. Terminal on lahti aga ta on lahti, tegelikult, ja siis, kui Nüüd siin. Ee
Õpetaja: aa, okei. Mis asi puudu veel on? Sul tegelikult Jah,
Õpetaja: korra vaatan mulje pärast Saab aru küll, et ta on
Õpetaja: unustas minna Zoomi kaugele
Õpetaja: Praegu nagu ei tunne. Ta ei saa aru. Vaata, et sul on seal olemas. Ta nagu veits saab, aru aga mitte Nagu,
Õpetaja: Ee, päris lõpuni.
Õpetaja: Nii, Aa, salvestus. Jah, Mm, kahe kohe. Kus on selge nupp?
Õpetaja: Oi, aga recording vist ütleb rekord. Minu. Mul oli Hoopis oli Screenshare oli pausi peal.
Õpetaja: Jah, nii et viisteist minutit sai keegi vaadata seda videot? Võib olla niisama kerida.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, lähme edasi
Õpetaja: Saime Rita ka selle trikiga suht kiirelt otsa peale, nii et tundub, et töötab ka teistes arvutites. Nii et väga hea on teada seda,
Õpetaja: Ee, nii, millest nüüd tahame siis alustada Ongi see, et kui te teete lahti Frontend ist. Aa, Frontendiga. Osta
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd. Eeldus on see, et front end ja Back and server töötavad üldse. Kui teil ei ole siin stop nuppu koos number kahega, siis tähendab seda, et ükski Server hetkel ei tööta. Ee, ehk mina pean panema käima oma fronti.
Õpetaja: Siis ma tulen ja panen Ee Backendi. Tegelikult praegult isegi ei ole vaja käima panna. Me ei toimeta seal või midagi otseselt sealt. Ee, seal ei ole mitte midagi, et frontend ist nagu piisab
Õpetaja: nüüd, asi, Mis Võiks teada? Ee, frontend. I puhul on selline, et ee, voes ja frontend is on toetatud. Selline tehnoloogia nagu hotelli lood.
Õpetaja: Hotelliloo tähendab Seda, et me võime koodibaasis teha mingisuguseid muudatusi. Aga me ei pea serverit ise uuesti käivitama, et neid muutusi niiöelda näha Backendis meil niukest Luksust pole seal. On niimoodi. Iga kord, kui sa kirjutad mingi aava koodi, ee, kirjutad valmis ja siis sa pead sellega ee, niiöelda uuesti käivitama, et ta saaks aru, et see taustal toimib. Miks see nii on? Vot võibolla natuke teooriat ka. Hakkame vaikselt
Õpetaja: võibolla rääkima mõningatest tähtsatest asjadest.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma lähen Atlasse, panen teile esimese lingi ka sinna. Mida pärast? Siis? Võibolla natuke pikemalt vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ee, lähen otsin
Õpetaja: võibolla korra, Nagu näitan nagu üldist setup. I ka, et te saaksite aru, mis põhimõtteliselt on võimalik
Õpetaja: Ee, Bcshb. Läheme sinna.
Õpetaja: Aa, siin selles. Ee, see See koht, kus teil on ligipääs, Seal on tegelikult mitu, Space? Meil on eraldi Vali Id.
Õpetaja: Kui lähed siia, vali It peale, siis siin On kõik Vali It, Staff
Õpetaja: Ee, ja üks, asi, mis siin on, on eelkursus. Vali tee portal. Siin siis ongi niimoodi üks koolitus koolitus, Mis põhimõtteliselt on siin niimoodi punktide kaupa ära toodud ja millega saab hakata õppima niiöelda tarkvara arendust, siis ee selle programmi järgi
Õpetaja: noh, esimene Ee, sprint. Siin on sprintideks asi jaotatud. Ee, sellest pikemalt ei räägi. See on lihtsalt osadeks jaotatud.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: Ee teatud see põhimõtteliselt ta nagu Töötas niimoodi, et üks print on kaks nädalat Need õpilased Siis nagu tegid kaks nädalat. Mingeid asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegid. Ee, seal õppisid, proovisid harjutasid Ja Siis liikusid edasi järgmise kahe nädala peale. See koolitus on teile selles mõttes nagu kättesaadav. Ee, ja te saate seda vaadata. Aga põhiline asi on. See tegelikult on materjalid. Ise on Knowledge base all
Õpetaja: ja Knowledge all. On siis näiteks, mida ma tahaks nüüd rääkida, on ee, Vadis Java Sourcefile.
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen juba selle lingi. Panen näiteks ka.
Õpetaja: Te võiksite seda vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ma panen ta generali alla What is source File. Ja ma võtan siit selle lingi ka ja teen selle lingiks.
Õpetaja: Saada kiirelt sinna.
Õpetaja: Ahah, nüüd üks väike konks. Muidugi on Ee, Karli Vist Hetkel ei saanud ligi. Karli vaatab lihtsalt praegu ekraanilt. Pärast tegeleme sellega. Ee, kuidas tema saaks ka ligi? Ee, ja siin põhimõtteliselt siis selgitab. Vaata, mis asi on Lähtekood. Et kui me java mõttes nagu vaatame seda eriti
Õpetaja: ee java mõttes, meil on siin selline fail nagu Bank Application. See on nüüd Lähtekood, punkt Java fail.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas see töötab, on see, et meil on Jaova fail ja meil on selline programm nagu java kompilaator. Ja tema võtab põhimõtteliselt vanasti pidi käsitsi ühe faili kaupa ise käske käivitama, et. Hei, siin on minu kood. Vaata, Tee see paik koodiks.
Õpetaja: Jaava kompilaator. Siis teeb selle Bike koodiks. Ja siis ta on punkt Classiga. Ja see mõte on nüüd see, et, Ee, kuidas. Mis on Nagu see, et kuidas? Mis on nagu jaava. Nii populaarne on see, et nad on teinud sellise lahenduse,
Õpetaja: et nad on teinud. Ee, igale eraldi keskkonnale. Näiteks Windows Ile Linuxile Macile kohvi ee keetjale. Mida iganes. Ee, tehakse eraldi programmeeritud. Masin
Õpetaja: et on nagu Niukene vahelüli. Vaata, Windows is on Jaova Virtuaalmasin. Linuxis on Jaova virtuaalmasin. Ja siis Ee Macis on Ee Jaova Virtuaalmasin. Ee. Ja nüüd kui Sa tahad jooksutada? Java? Ee, paitkoodi. Mis on paitkood? Lähme natukene allapoole Korraks Siin
Õpetaja: pait. Kood on midagi taolist. Kaheksa numbri kaupa, nullid ja Ühed.
Õpetaja: See on pait kood.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas neil on siis see süsteem ära lahendatud, et, ee. Põhimõtteliselt siis see java virtuaalmasin Windows keskkonnas, tema juba teab, kuidas koodi on võimalik jooksutada. Windows is.
Õpetaja: Kui see on Jaova virtuaalne asi, mis on Linuxis, söö ta talle sisse põhimõtteliselt java paitkood Ja ta teab, kuidas see Linuxis peab. Siis mis? Mis peab juhtuma ja Maciga samamoodi. Kui me mõtleme seda Flow D, siis see Põhimõtteliselt on niimoodi, et meil on arendaja, kes kirjutab koodi.
Õpetaja: Näed, see on Human Readable Code.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleb. Kompilaator. On Niukene vend.
Õpetaja: Tema siis võtab selle. Ee, selle faili. Ee, teeb ta punkti Avas klassis teeb punkt Classic ja see punkt Classi sees on juba ehedamal kujul paitsioon ülitehed.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on Jaova virtuaalmasin. Noh, tema näiteks elab siis Windowsi sees. Tema nüüd võtab vastu selle bike koodi ja tegelikult teeb ta Siis seal selles keskkonnas. Selle keskkonna käskud, eks?
Õpetaja: Vaid, et midagi peaks toimuma.
Õpetaja: Ja lõpuks siis seal täiesti taustal protsessor siis midagi teeb ja Siis näita, et lihtsalt käivitad koodi, mis lihtsalt prindib konsooli. Hello World.
Õpetaja: Sihukene Flow on siis teile teadmiseks, nüüd, kui me räägime Frontend ist,
Õpetaja: Siis Frontend ei ole. See on nagu Jaava. On kompileeritav kood. Just seda, mis ma rääkisin praegu. Me kompileerime. Me võtame ühe soo lähtekoodi Ja kompileerime ta tegelikult siis nagu antud juhul paitkoodiks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Java script ei ole. Ee, bike Kood Ee kompileeritav kood java. Kui ma vihkan Seda sõna java script. Ehk siis see kood, mis jooksetab seal frontend. Is. Niiöelda funktsionaalsus. Javascript on interpreteeritav
Õpetaja: kool. Ja selle vahe on see, et seal põhimõtteliselt arvuti. No päeva lõpuks, see peab samamoodi kõik kuidagi protsessorini jõudma. Ta peab seal midagi toimetama ja tegema, onju,
Õpetaja: et kui Jaaval on niimoodi. Vaata, et see eelnevalt on ära tehtud nullideks ühtedeks ja protsessor oskab selle ka majandada. Vaata, et seal on mingid käsud Ja värgid, Mis iganes on ju siis ee. Jaavaskriptiga on niimoodi, et ta selle jooksutamise hetkel vaatab seda koodi ja tõlgendab selle linnulennult, siis Põhimõtteliselt nendeks käskudeks,
Õpetaja: Mis seal konkreetses süsteemis peab siis toimuma nagu nagu Windows ja Mac, Onju, et seal on vahe,
Õpetaja: aga siin tulebki nagu Juba see nagu välja. Miks see hotelli laud töötab? Nagu, ee. Seal. Selles frontend is ongi see, et vaata, et seda seda ei kompileerita ümber vaid sellel hetkel. Kui sa käivitad koodi, siis lihtsalt kiirelt tõlgendatakse see käskudeks
Õpetaja: ja ta oskab seda nagu hotellile otses, nagu ta oskab seda suht lihtsalt teha, nagu. Vaata uuesti kiirelt. Vaatab, et mina muudan ühe tähe ära. Vaatan, mis peab taustal muutma, aga ei ole. Kirjutad uue. Mingi loogika ja funktsionaalsuse
Õpetaja: kompulaator peab selle tegema ennem nullideks. Ühtedeks Server tuleb taas käivitada ja talle tuleb anda sisse need palgid,
Õpetaja: et See on see põhiline vahe. Kuidas see siis nagu päriselt on, et kui te panite Frontend I käima, siis näete. Teil tekib Niukene Link Lokalhost. Kaheksakümmend, kaheksakümmend, Üks
Õpetaja: praegult. Ee, Tema näitab ainult selle indeks. Html i Sisu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida ta näitab? See on Html. Dokument
Õpetaja: See on Html. See on siis kirjaviis, millest nii arvuti kui ka tavainimene, saavad mõlemad tegelikult aru. Ja see Body osa, mis on siin kohe räägime Natukene rohkem kui Htmlist. Ja kõigest on osa, mis on nähtav. Hetkel on ainult siin tegelikult üks rida teksti,
Õpetaja: mis on tegelikult selle Body, sees. Sest et ülejäänud on lihtsalt kas välja kommenteeritud või ongi nagu kommentaarid. Asjad, mida teha, kui mina võtan siit eest ära selle osa Siit
Õpetaja: ja selle osa siit, siis ta on nagu osa sellest koodist. Kui ma praegu vaataksin. Nüüd,
Õpetaja: kui ma teen selle runmenüü lahti, otsin Selle Frontend I Scrollin ülesse. Teen selle lingi. Lahti. Siis siin aitab. Tere, maailm Vaatame veel hypertekst. Marc, mida iganes ma panen Control Setiga. Teen niimoodi, et need kommentaari asjad on seal sees jälle. Ja siis ta on ainult kommentaar. See on ainukene osa praegu, tegelikult päris koodist.
Õpetaja: Ja mis nüüd üldse mõte on? See, et on hot riilod on see, et kui ma koodis teen, Aa,
Õpetaja: siis siia tuleb ka kohe. Ah, aa, Ma ei pidanud serverit käivitama. Sul on hoteli Lood. On kellegil küsimusi. Hoteli loode osas
Õpetaja: vist mitte suht Niukene Basic statut,
Õpetaja: nüüd Mida meie tegema hakkame, on see, et me tahame kõik siin kenasti toimetada.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei saa kõike kenasti toimetada,
Õpetaja: Vaid nüüd on siis Selline hetk, kus me teeme niimoodi, et me teeme igaüks iseenda haru. Mäletate selle selle kit? I? Mõte oli see, et kuidas me saame töötada ühest samas projektist teineteist segamata, nagu ma rääkisin. Mina ja Jaroslave ei saa samal ajal kirjutada koodi. Tema tahab kustutada ja tema tahab A tähte panna. Mina tahan B tähtede plaani. No mis, Kuidas asi peaks tulema? Onju
Õpetaja: siis ongi see, et, ee, kõige esimese sammuna. Ee, Komite. Ruttu need ka siia ära
Õpetaja: saab vaadata. Mis see Kit Bruun Täpselt, teeb? Panen Kit and Comit, bla blabla. Panen selle sinna ära.
Õpetaja: Teie võite teha ka ja update.
Õpetaja: Tulete siia, vajutate
Õpetaja: siis me kõik alustame samal positsioonilt. Aa, vot. Vabandust, ma. Mul ei ole veel välja pushinud. Sorry,
Õpetaja: nägite? Ma kummittisin ära aga ta ei ole veel välja pushind. Punane joon.
Õpetaja: Miski ei lähe pilve ennem, kui mina ise ütlen. Ja Ta küsib üle. Mul ka Näed. Vajutasin buss. Ta on nagu, et. No mitu korda ma seda Push I vajutan kaks korda sellepärast, et see on see. See on see Joon, Vaata, et kus peab olema nagu ettevaatlik.
Õpetaja: Nüüd te saate teha, Fetch ja siis ta peaks jälle. Näitama, et te olete ühe ühe niiöelda komiitiga. Olete maas
Õpetaja: That the fedge
Õpetaja: Sest et, ee, update selle masteri pealt.
Õpetaja: Siin on nüüd Selline värk. Ee, te saate nagu. Vot vanasti. Sellist asja ei olnud. Isegi see tuli Mingi Aeg tagasi tuli sse. Te saate nagu erinevad Harud, mis teil on olemas Saate siit alt näppida ja valida igast valikud. Mis siis saab? Aga need valikud, mis on siin üleval lihtsalt kehtivad selle haru kohta kus te hetkel olete.
Õpetaja: Ehk siit vajutades Ee, Update project või siit vajutades update, on tegelikult üks ja see sama asi, Masterharu. Update
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: kui te nüüd olete selle ära teinud, nüüd on siis see samm, kus me ee, meie teed, nagu lähevad lahku, Mina teen seda ka kaasa Samamoodi. Ee, Tulge selle harumajanduse peale ja valige siit New Branch.
Õpetaja: Mida see nüüd teeb? On see, et kõik, Mis praegult hetkel siin? Kõik failid. Täpselt sellisel viisil, nagu nad on. Me teeme nüüd oma haru, kus me saame toimetada. Mina panen siia, Õpetaja,
Õpetaja: teie pange suurte tähtedega oma nimi. Lihtsalt meil vist. Ee. Ühtegi eest. Nime ei kattu. Nii et piis piisab eest nimest.
Õpetaja: Kui te Tahate te võite juba ette panna Siia, V. Üks versioon Üks ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, see eelkõige. See praeguses hetkes. Tegelikult nii tähtis ei ole, aga Siis kui me hakkame päris Aa asju tegema. Ee, siis. Ee. Siis. Tegelikult on see, et te teete mingisugust tööd.
Õpetaja: Te jäte minust maha, Mingi asi on katki. Mingi asi läheb punaseks. Me ei hakka uurima, miks kellelgi on midagi punane? Kuskil on Mingi kool on puudu või? Jumal Teab mis. Vaata, Sest et see ei anna meile mitte mingisugust väärtust.
Õpetaja: Selles Mõttes me peame klassiruumis õppima neid teemasid Meil on palju asju katta. Vaatame. Lähme kogu aeg edasi.
Õpetaja: Siis on see, et kuidas te saate hästi kiirelt järgi tulla, On alati olnud, see et te Lihtsalt Võtate minu harust ühe uue haru ja panete sinna V kaks,
Õpetaja: Ja siis. See vana asi jääb teil alles, kui te tahate pärast uurida ja puurida, et. Ee. Noh, mis seal siis valesti on? Kas kui näiteks Ee Cloud code i abiga, või mis iganes onju, siis Te saate seda pärast seda teha, on ju? Teil jääb kõik see staff alles. Te saate kogu aeg võtta uue haru,
Õpetaja: et. Noh, ma Teen Siis näite. Jaroslav V, Üks Jaroslav V, Kaks V, kolm ja nii edasi. Te saate tulla kiirelt mulle järgi. Kõik on nagu tähtähed, Sama, mis nagu mina. Mis me kokku lepime. Selleks on siis see, et lihtsalt Kui keegi tahab järgi tulla, siis ütleb Rain T üks Committ, Siis Minu jaoks tähendab see, et ma teen. Teen siis,
Õpetaja: et see läheb pilve Annan aega korraks. Teie teete siis endale fetch i
Õpetaja: Update I update Ei ole vaja teha. Teete ee ja tulete. Võtate minu aru pealt New Branch.
Õpetaja: Paned uuesti oma nime ja panete sinna, Siis ma ei tea, E, Kaks, mis iganes. Kas mõte on Selge? Eesmärk on, see, et te saate hästi kiirelt tulla mulle järgi
Õpetaja: ja minna edasi. Nagu, et see ei ole väärtus, et kuskil on midagi. Mingi Mingi asi on katki. Kohe loetunnis. Me võime vaadata, aga vähemalt tunni ajal Me läheks lihtsalt edasi, on ju nii? Mina teen õpetaja. Praegu lihtsalt. Te võite praegu teha ka. Esialgu lihtsalt no võite vaadata Selle V ühe ka ei pea Ükstaspuha.
Õpetaja: Ee, näed, seal all oli ka. Tegelikult oli niuke tikpoks nagu checkout. Ta teeb siis kaks toimingut korraga ära.
Õpetaja: Ta aktiveeris mul selle aru. Teil nüüd peaks siin kõigil ees olema. Ee, enda nimi on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui teha see Kit I tööriist alt lahti. Ma pean kõik muud asjad kinni siit vaadata. Siis te peaksite nüüd nägema oma lokali all Master It ja siis enda nime. Aga Remodi all peaks olema kõik veel sama.
Õpetaja: Nüüd võib kohe ära proovida, et kas ta üldse on nagu Repo õigused olemas,
Õpetaja: kui Te panete siit nüüd Ee, selle õpetaja pealt. Mitte õpetaja. Pealt enda aru. Pealt, Push.
Õpetaja: Siis peaks tulema Niukene asi lahti, nagu origin ja Teie nimi. Ta ütleb, et kas te tahate, et teie kohalik haru muutuks ka pilveharuks? Mäletate Remote Origin Track Branch tähendab alati pilve,
Õpetaja: on Nii,
Õpetaja: push, Ida ta ära, Siis see peaks põhimõtteliselt minema Pilve. See võib natukene aega võtta.
Õpetaja: Noh, mul tegi juba ära, kui siis, kui Teil ei oleks, Kui ma ei oleks teid projekti pannud. Kui collaborator, siis te ei oleks saanud seda liigutust teha.
Õpetaja: Teil on oma kit Up I konto.
Õpetaja: Mis sest, et see on Public nii öelda projekt, mida igaüks saab kuskil downloadida ja vaadata onju
Õpetaja: siis selles mõttes, tööd Saab seal ainult teha see, kellel on luba antud.
Õpetaja: Mingi võõras inimene ei saa tulla koodibaasi muutma,
Õpetaja: mitte ennem, kui see kuidagi ühel või Teisel viisil on lubatud. Kui mina näiteks nüüd, teen, siis suure tõenäosusega see remoodi alla peaks tulema veel
Õpetaja: neid haarusi, kes on Push I teinud. Ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd See ei ole praegu kuidagi tähtis, et teil see pilves on. Ja Ma juba ütlen teile ette ära, et mis me Nüüd järgmisena hakkame tegema. Me hakkame vaatama neid tehnoloogiaid. Html, Ccs ja Javascript. Niimoodi Step by step,
Õpetaja: Kõik see, mis me praegult nüüd teeme, Edasi, Praeg. Nagu alates praegusest hetkest. Kuni teatud hetkeni on prügikasti Kaup
Õpetaja: tähendab seda. Vaata, et see ei ole nagu meie päris projekt, mida Me hakkame tegema, mida ma eile näitasin teile, Et mida me hakkame tegema.
Õpetaja: See on alles see, et me lihtsalt õpime tundma, et mis On üldse meie mängumaa? Nagu mida? Mida, Mis võtteid me saame kasutada? Ee, et oma frontend I niiöelda ehitada.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on nagu see ka, et, ee kuna see on niikuinii prügikasti kaup, siis ei pea isegi tingimata kaasa tegema. Aga Võib, kui jääd maha, siis tule lihtsalt järgi. Aa, ei ole mõtet kirjutada sinna mingisuguseid kommentaare Ja asju. Vaata endale, et see on see, et too on too. Jätke lihtsalt meelde võimalused.
Õpetaja: Te ei pea mitte midagi õppima. Selles mõttes süntaksi mõttes. Teil Ei, ole vaja nagu siia teha, et kuidas teha Näiteks, ma ei tea linki, kuidas lingi nagu struktuur käib. Html is
Õpetaja: Ee või?
Õpetaja: Sest ee tuleb vajutada. Login.
Õpetaja: Aa, vaadake. Browser. Browser on aga Browser pilkku Ma ei pannud selgelt.
Õpetaja: Okei, hetkel Aa, ignoreerige. Pange, uurime seda vahetunnis.
Õpetaja: Ee, pigem lõunapause, mis ka väga kaugel enam ei ole. See on Vaatamise värk. Ee, teie haru praegu pilves ei ole otseselt vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga uurime. Seda Aga kõigil ei olnud seda muret. Onju?
Õpetaja: Keegi sai nagu Bushidega. Aga kas ta. Kas ta tegi sul browser I lahti ja siis läksid? Sinna? Vaadake, äkki on Chromis või kuskil. Vaata, aga palun, Ärme tegele sellega, stop. Nagu ülisavi, Nagu tegeleme sellega pärast.
Õpetaja: See ei ole üldse tähtis.
Õpetaja: Te ei jää. Millestki maha. Ja praegu on nagu Nii vaatamise koht Koersaarme lõunale niikuinii tunni aja pärast.
Õpetaja: Nii, millest ma nüüd tegelikult, ee, tahan rääkida, on siis ee, Alustame siis sellest Html Ist
Õpetaja: et mis asi on? Ee, Html.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul Tegelikult on ka mõned vanad materjalid. Ee, mis natukene ühtteist Räägivad? Ee.
Õpetaja: Ee. Vaatame lihtsalt neid läbi Minu arvuti.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul ei ole neid kahju s? Aga need on niuksed. Tilulilud Niikuinii
Õpetaja: Ei, tegelt on ka kust, või on, Ma Ei mäleta, kust nad on ja nad on ikkagi abis pole. Vaata, on ju.
Õpetaja: Ee, Olete kuulnud üldse Html?
Õpetaja: Html on siis ee Pikalt on hypertekst Marko Language
Õpetaja: Päri teksti märgistuskeel. Noh, näete, kui kõik oleks eesti keeles oleks päris hõbe.
Õpetaja: Ee, millega on tegemist, tegemist on Siis sellise dokumendiga, mida Brauser oskab siis visualiseerida,
Õpetaja: et kui ee näiteks teha see minu ja Apollo kino paide, või mul ei ole mingit Ma Ei, saa neid mingit raha, tasuta, pääsemid ega midagi. Aga ma kasutan tihtipeale näitena pollo kino, et see sama veebilehekülg kinokavad niiöelda mis on on tegelikult taustal, kui vaadata Page Source
Õpetaja: on Html. Dokument See on tekstifail,
Õpetaja: sest et ega ei ole võimalik kuidagi. Noh, kui keegi üldse kunagi. On seda nagu väga mõelnud onju, et ei ole võimalik kuidagi automaagiliselt saata kellegi Browser Isse nagu niukest visuaalset interaktiivset pilti,
Õpetaja: vaid saab saata. Põhimõtteliselt siis ikkagi. Päeva. Lõpuks, kui me hästi nagu raua Tasandile läheme, siis on kaine mingi nullid ja ühed mis teevad mingid Käsud ja asjad. Aga. Aga nagu siis lihtsamas, Printsiibis on nagu mõelda seda, et tegemist on tekstidokumendiga.
Õpetaja: No kui kui proovida näiteks siit midagi et Siin on kirjas. Kinokava koostatakse ette üheks nädalaks.
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen otsin sellest. Html Ist Control F
Õpetaja: Okei, Jumal teab, kuidas see kokku pannakse. Võta midagi lihtsamalt. Kinokava filmid. Proovime niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, otsing. Control F. Kino kava.
Õpetaja: Näete, titel Kino kava See Tegelikult on üldse
Õpetaja: see siin. Ee, oota, Ma Võtan korra lahti oma. See on üldse tital. See on kinokava. Pole kino.
Õpetaja: See osa siin.
Õpetaja: Aga mitmes teises kohas on Ka Ehk siis meil on Niukene dokument, mida oskab niiöelda inimene lugeda ja oskab siis ee, põhimõtteliselt ka kasutaja lugeda
Õpetaja: ja ta koosneb ee Ta hakkab niimoodi et on meil see dokument ise.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis on meil head osa. Ja Body osa
Õpetaja: nüüd head osa on ee, siukene Osa, mis tegelikult suuresti ei ole väga nähtav. Sinna saab igasugust staffi panna. Sinna saab panna linke script idele. Sinna saab panna linke stiilidele Seal saab igasuguseid asju teha. Ainukene nähtav osa. Mis seal tõesti on?
Õpetaja: Ee, üldse on titel, et kui me vaatame seda, et meil on siin. Vite app.
Õpetaja: Kui me. Vaatame oma lokaalset serverit, siis siin. Ee, tab i peal, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ee Selles, head osas, Ahah, Ma natukene Räägin nagu tag idest ka. Kuigi see tuleb veel In a bit. Vaata, on ju. Ee, siin on Niukene süsteem, et iga asi on siin niiöelda arvuti jaoks talle vaja saada aru skoobist ehk ulatuses.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, see tegelikult see tag. Seda kutsutakse tag Iks, Millest kohe räägin, ma Ka ta koosneb. Kahest osast on algus
Õpetaja: Ja see sidekriip. Ee, kaldkriipsuga osa on tema lõpp. Kõik, mis on selle vahel, on head osa Ja siin on eraldi. Algab lõppeb Ja päris Title on siin keskel. Kui ma panen siia Aa, siis on loomulikult selle Täby nimi Aa,
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: See head osa on tegelikult Ee, suuresti nähtamatu osa.
Õpetaja: Ee, Nüüd, mis on nähtav osa, on Body osa,
Õpetaja: Kui me, siit Vaatame meie. Body algab siit
Õpetaja: reaalt üheksa Ja kui tulla siia tööriistal. Niiöelda Ee siia reanumbrite juurde, Niukene väike, osa et ta saab, aru et see koosneb kahest poolest. Ma väitan niimoodi selle peale. Siis ta tõmbab selle kokku,
Õpetaja: et Real sada seitseteist. Või siis pigem sada kuusteist on tema teine pool
Õpetaja: ägedast. Kui ma lähen, lähed poodi, algab. Lähme reale Sada kuusteist.
Õpetaja: Siis siin Boodi lõppeb.
Õpetaja: See. On, See et kõik, Mis on, siin Body sees? See nüüd on siis see nähtav osa leheküljest
Õpetaja: Body Sees on praegult kiri. Tere maailm. Järelikult meil näidatakse tere Maailm
Õpetaja: kui Body sees. Ma panen Control D. Tublid.
Õpetaja: Tere, majand. Tere, majand. Ära Maailm. Siis on seal samamoodi küll, ainult niimoodi, et nad on ju kõik ühel real.
Õpetaja: Aga nad on olemas.
Õpetaja: Vot nii, sa teed. Söön poodi. Poodi ise.
Õpetaja: Nii, vaatame, mis veel räägitakse. No okei, Rohkem sellest, Ee, väga palju. Ei olegi, et tegemist on dokumendiga. Kui vaadata, Vaadake, siit ülevalt hakkab esimene asi Onl
Õpetaja: See siis on nagu Põhimõtteliselt ee kokku lepitud. Tehnoloogia, standard,
Õpetaja: Kõik põhimõtteliselt. Kui tehakse mingeid uuendusi, et selle Atml is on võimalik, mingi uusi fookus. Pookusi, teha, siis Ee, ta põhimõtteliselt. Mingi suur kontsertsium on, kes lepib kokku põhimõtteliselt. Ja nüüd teeme mingi niukse Asja
Õpetaja: Lepime, kokku, et see asi, mis siin Nüüd saab Atml is teha. On sellises kirjaviisis Töötab sellisel viisil. See on standard.
Õpetaja: Ta on Htm L. Standard.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: ja. Ja tänapäeval vist On mingi Html viis äkki on keegi kuulnud? Vaata, et see on nagu, kus kõige uuemad browserid toetavad seda kõike kenasti.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme, edasi, Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, siis järgmine asi on. Mis asi on, Html Cscs jaavaskrit, et vaatame korra neid tervikuna.
Õpetaja: Ee, põhimõtteliselt siis htm. Ccss Javascripto on Kolm põhitehnoloogiat, mida kasutatakse veebilehtede loomiseks ja kuvamiseks. Ja igaüks mängib nendest erinevat kuid olulist rolli veebilehe kujundamisel, et vaatame kõike neid eraldi, aga. Siis vaatame neid koos ka. On ju
Õpetaja: Html I. Peamine mõte on, see et ta annab meile veebilehe struktuuri ja sisu.
Õpetaja: Me räägime nüüd seda sellisel viisil. Vaata, et et stiilis, Et meil on ripmenüü kuskil.
Õpetaja: Meil on kastikene kuhu saab teksti kirjutada. Meil on teksti tekst. Kus on paragrahv mingi tekstilõik.
Õpetaja: Meil on pealkiri.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kuskil seal niuksed nagu ma ei tea, pool viis ja suuremad, meil on pilt,
Õpetaja: meil On Ee, link.
Õpetaja: Meil on checkbox, kuskil checkboxid radiopatonid, Lihtsalt nupud,
Õpetaja: kõik Need asjad. On sisu ja struktuur. Et java script Noh, saab ka Veits fookus pookust teha on ju. Aga näiteks Css. Iga ei ole võimalik ee tekitada meil juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee, näiteks mingit uut pilti uut sisu, Ee, nagu mingisuguseid. Ee, veerge, ee, ridu ja Nii, edasi. Vaata, et see Html on meie ainukene mängumaa, millega me saame põhimõtteliselt veebilehel, öelda et siin on mingi siuke asi. Siin on mingi siuke asi.
Õpetaja: Siin on mingi siuke asi.
Õpetaja: Pilt, menüü, Checkbox. Mida iganes nüüd Css, tema on siis ee niiöelda stiili ja veebilehe paigutuse jaoks.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis kui me räägime, et mul on seal veebilehel Näiteks kaks pilti, siis on küsimus. Vaata, et kas neil on mingid raamid ümber. Kas seal on mingid varjud ümber? Kas nad on üksteise kõrval? Kas üks on teise peal.
Õpetaja: Kas ma hoian mingisugusest asjast nii Palju eemale või nii palju eemale või nii palju eemale. See kõik on Csss.
Õpetaja: Seda hakkame Me Vaatame need eraldi ja Java script on siis programmeerimisskeem, mis võimaldab ee, siis veebilehele lisada funktsionaalsust ja interaktiivsust
Õpetaja: et Ee Html on ee struktuur Ja Sisu Css on stiil ja paigutus. Ja Javascript on funktsionaalsus ja action. Noh, ütleme niimoodi. Interaktiivsus Need kolm teevad siis veebilehest veebilehe tänapäeval
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: mm, no siin on näide ka. Vaata, näiteks siin on Html, Css ja Java Script. Loomulikult, Apollo Kinod, et taustal on siis need Kolm asja, mis teevad selle asja selliseks.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on kainda nagu näide. Vaata, et, ee, Html ilma Cssita nii palju kui ma oskasin maha nudida, et nagu sisu on, aga pole nagu mingit stiili.
Õpetaja: No ja avascript. Kui midagi klikid, siis midagi toimub.
Õpetaja: Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, siis, ee, Järgmine asi Miks, Miks võiks vaadata on? Siis hakkame Html I niimoodi lahti pookima, et, Ee, Kuidas Html
Õpetaja: toetavad? Hästi, natukene juba rääkisin sellest,
Õpetaja: Html Märgendid. Noh, see on nüüd Eesti keeles. See on ainult üks. Ja ainus kord, kus me seda kasutame. Märgendid, Me ei hakka rääkima, et Kas on? Märgendid algavad ja lõppevad nagu tagid.
Õpetaja: Ee on siis veebilehtede struktuuri ja sisu niiöelda Aa määramiseks Niiöelda mõned neist vajavad algus Ja lõpptähist samas kui teised. Mitte
Õpetaja: Ee, põhjus on selles, et mõned märgendid vajavad täpsustamist. Millal nende mõju algab ja lõpeb samas kui teised on iseseisvad.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, võib siin tuua, siis näiteid ka. Näiteks et, ee, tekstilõik.
Õpetaja: Tekstilõik. See ongi tegelikult tekstilõik. Paragrahv.
Õpetaja: No ütleme, kui loed. Ee, raamatut. Vaata, sa lõigud. Vaata, onju. Mingi üks lõik, teine lõik, sest saad ka enda aru, Kus, nagu mingid väiksed vahepausid on,
Õpetaja: et, Ee, kui siukest asja soovid teha, siis kogu see tekst peaks olema kahe sellise tag i vahel. Paragrahv algab. Paragrahv lõppeb
Õpetaja: ee, teksti baldiks, Tegemine. Strong ja Strong lõpp. No see on mingi lambi näited. Need on kahe tag. Iga
Õpetaja: Need on sellised elemendid. Neid kutsutakse tegelikult elementideks. Kõik need asjad, need erinevad asjad. See ripp, menüü, see kastikene. Ee, tekstpilt. Aa, need on Html elemendid, osad, elemendid Ehk osad on ju
Õpetaja: Ee, see on nagu niuke. Õige keel, et osad elemendid on siis kahe tagiga ja osad on ühega
Õpetaja: näiteks pildil.
Õpetaja: Pildil ei ole nagu Selles mõttes algus ja lõpp. Pildil on põhimõtteliselt vaja, öelda, et sa oled pilt ja kust tuleb tegelikult sinu sisu, nagu andmete mõttes, võibolla Veel nagu see ka, et ee, et kui pilti pilt on katki, et seda pildi sisu pole võimalik renderdada, siis on näiteks alternatiivne tekst, Vaata, et ma ei tea, Siin on mingi Lhv.
Õpetaja: Ee, kaart Midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Break näiteks. Break on. Lihtsalt tee üks reavahetus. Tal ei ole vaja algust ja lõppu. Ta on. Lihtsalt tee lehele reavahetus.
Õpetaja: Tegin sellised lambinäited.
Õpetaja: Mida me nüüd hakkame? Tegema Noh, see on siis kaasategemise kohta Võib ka pealt vaadata, et me hakkame tegema niuke üheksakümnendate stiilis veebilehte pangale.
Õpetaja: Mäletate? Aa, üheksakümnendates stiilis lehed need olid tegelikult väga brutaalsed Ee Kainda nagu ühevärvilised
Õpetaja: Ee, vahel. Keegi hull inimene oli pannud ka mingi vilkuvaid asju. Juurde. Jumal hoidku, kui pandi ka mingi muusika taustal käima, Värvid olid niuksed. See Aqua oli hästi niisugune, populaarne. Minu meelest niukest
Õpetaja: türkiis, sinist ja mingit kärbunast ja kõik, see, et me teeme nagu Lihtsalt niukse väikse nagu, Aa, väikse lehekülje teeme. Kus siis põhimõtteliselt on? Nagu mingi panga lehekülg, kus saab mingit uut klienti, näiteks lisada midagi taolist me teeme.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siin tõesti. Eesmärk on ainult tutvuda nende elementidega mitte meelde jätta. Kuidas neid kirjutatakse? Seda Pole vaja,
Õpetaja: pole vaja
Õpetaja: Ee, jätta meelde, kuidas kirjutatakse. See on Pointless. Lihtsalt teadmine, et kui ma tahan pilti, siis siuke võimalus on olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahan lipp menüüd, siis siuke. Võimalus on olemas. Kui ma tahan kasti, kus Trip Toad teksti, Siis on? Võimalus, kui ma tahan task kasti, kus on Näiteks, et ta ei näe, mida kirjutad, siis selline võimalus on olemas, kui ma tahan. Ee, näiteks kalendri valikut. Ma tahan kuupäeva valida, siis Siuke, asi on olemas. Vot see on see mõte.
Õpetaja: Teadmine, mis on nagu need põhilised asjad, ega kõik, mis me siit läbi teeme, kõik teile Tegelikult on tuttavad asjad mida te olete veebilehtedel näinud. Midagi põrutavat Teile ei tule ainult teadmine.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt hakkame pihta Heederitest. Heeder, Ehk siis Pealkiri
Õpetaja: Tahame teha niukse, pealkiri meie pank ja eriti äge pank. Tahame teha, et see meie pank on vähe suurem ja eriti äge Pank Oleks seal kohe all, nagu natukene väiksemad.
Õpetaja: Kuidas seda saab teha?
Õpetaja: Selle jaoks on H. Üks
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siin. Väiksed konksud. Vaata, et, ee, See tööriist tegelikult ei ole mõeldud nagu täielikult Fronti Ee progemiseks. Aga ta tegelikult toetab seda küllaltki hästi kui panna H üks ja nüüd vajutada Tab, siis ta teeb sellest kahe
Õpetaja: kahe kahese tag. I, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ma control Setting. Võtan ise korra tagasi. Kui ma kirjutan siia Ja vajutan, Tab, siis ta mõtleb ka, et ma tahan teha niukest tag. I niukest ei ole Html is olemas, aga idee järgi see tööriist. Meil Niimoodi toimib.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen siit seda. H, üks ja tulen siit noolega niimoodi alla.
Õpetaja: H, üks, A, üks ja ta on hoolega alla võetan. Näiteks
Õpetaja: siis ta teeb ainult alguse. Aga see on nagu päris asi, mis on olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaksin, et ta on ühe täagiline, Siis ma panen kaldkriipsu ja ta lõpetab selle ära, et need elemendid, mis on ühe täag iga alternatiiv, on see, et ma Vajutan siit, Tab I
Õpetaja: ei. No okei, seda teeks lihtsalt niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd kui siia, ma kirjutan meie pank
Õpetaja: selle. Tere, võib siit ära kustutada. Tere, majandus. Oli Ainult selleks, et aru saada, et server töötab. Ee, pane näiteks meie pank.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd vaadata seda lehekülge, siis meie pank Ilmub kohe nähtavale, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ee, ei oska seda kasutada.
Õpetaja: See on see. Vaata, et ee. Kui Minul on üks programm lahti. Siit menüüst Tulen valin
Õpetaja: näiteks on lahti. Ja kui ma nüüd näiteks tulen, valin lihtsalt selle. Ee. Võtad Slaki
Õpetaja: Windows is. Saad lihtsalt kiirelt navigeerida nende asjade vahel, mis on juba lahti, Kui sa hoiad alti peal
Õpetaja: ja hakkad niimoodi Tabiga ükshaav minema. Nüüd minu. Mul näitab teisel ekraanil, kus ei ole Share. Siis sa saad niimoodi valida, et mis faili järgmiseks avad. Proovige. Oled alti peal
Õpetaja: tabiga. Klõps tuleb. Niukene Väikene menüü ette, Vaata, onju? Saad valida. See võib ka nüüd teisel ekraanil ja kuskil olla.
Õpetaja: Aga see Nüüd on see konks, et kui mina näiteks olen katsund ja olen katsund. Kui ma nüüd teen hästi kiirelt seda alt ja tab,
Õpetaja: siis ta valib lihtsalt eelmist asja kahe asja, vahel
Õpetaja: miks On see hea teada? On see, mida meie tahame teha, et kõigepealt kliki. Seda Intellige D klikki ühe korra Browser It
Õpetaja: ja nüüd alt Tabate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Saame kiirelt vaadata.
Õpetaja: Alternatiiv on loomulikult panna nad ka ühele ekraanile.
Õpetaja: Aga kui te vajutate Windows nuppu peale,
Õpetaja: hoiate all ja Vajuta noolekene paremale.
Õpetaja: Lased ta lahti ja valite näiteks mingi asja vasakule. Siis saab nii ka teha
Õpetaja: Reaalajas. Näed, ma võin proovida, kui ma Panen siia
Õpetaja: just. Pean klikkima Siia ikka. Vaata, et ta nagu aktiveeruks.
Õpetaja: Aga mulle endale, nagu väga see ei meeldi. Mulle meeldib pigem niimoodi, et ma lihtsalt hüppan. Nende vahel
Õpetaja: on kellegile küsimusi siinkohal, pole?
Õpetaja: Kas Sulle sobib. Teeme siis kella kaheteistkümneni ja siis, ee, teeme lõuna onju,
Õpetaja: Ja ongi. Ee. Kui ma nüüd teen siia alla. Vaata, tahan teha seda eriti ägedat panka. Ee, neid valikuid on. Või kui te vajutate, Lihtsalt siis üritab mõelda ka, et mida sa siin tahad teha? Vaata, onju. Siis te näete, et neid on kokku kuni tasemeni kuus,
Õpetaja: kui Ma panen siia näiteks. Noh, panen mingi H. Neli
Õpetaja: tab ja kirjutan siia. Eriti äge pank.
Õpetaja: Siis saame näha, et on erinevus.
Õpetaja: Täpselt nii Nagu sa mõtlesid. Aga kui ma panen H seitse, siis see on juba mingi jama, Sest et sellist asja pole olemas, panen mingi a Kaheksa,
Õpetaja: Vaata, joone tegi alla. Vaata, ta võtab seda kui lihtsalt tavatekst ja ta ei oska millestki muuks seda teha.
Õpetaja: Seal saab otsa.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Järgmine on paragrahv.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis mingi tekstilõik.
Õpetaja: Ee paragrahv. Juba Nagu seal koodi näites oli, oli siis B.
Õpetaja: Paragrahv algab. Paragrahv lõppeb selle teksti. Vaata, mis siin on, et siin need kommentaarid võib ära üldse kustutada. Ka nüüd siit. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: pole neid vaja. Ta on natuke puhtam, et Ee, mõte on, et kirjutame siia. No seda võib copida.
Õpetaja: Ahhaa mm, Mis, mis asi on? See Ei, see on vaenlane.
Õpetaja: See on arendaja Vaenlane.
Õpetaja: Mis sa arvad, miks ta on arendaja vaenlane?
Õpetaja: Seda võib ka olla aeglasem.
Õpetaja: Ee, point on see, et kui sa, oled, sa kirjutad koodi ja teed midagi, siis. Ee, uskuge või mitte, Kui te teete seda igapäevaselt, siis see liigutus, Kus te tunnete, et te olete sunnitud haarama hiire, nagu järgi mul tundub nagu sellel hetkel. Nagu et artriit hakkab juba tekkima vaikselt nagu sellesse rannasse.
Õpetaja: Ee, tegelikult, ee, on mõnus kirjutada koodi niimoodi, et käpad on klavertuuril. Sa oled juba paika pannud. Kui te olete kunagi märkand, kui te vaatate Keyboard i nuppe F Ja mis võiks nende puhul tähendada?
Õpetaja: Ja seal on väike väikene, niiöelda plastik. No mingi kõrgendus on. Vaata, et sa tunneksid, kus sul on, Kui sa oled oma käpad juba paika pannud. Isegi kui te ei hoia ennast päris õigesti ja mingi oma mingi stiil, mida viljeleda, on, Ju
Õpetaja: siis, ee. On nagu väga vastik. Kui sa pead võtma nagu käpad keyboard ilt ära ja siis tagasi panema ja siis ka enda Nagu otsima, et kuhu panna. Vaata või Card for Bid. Pead hakkama vaatama, kes pimekirja enamvähem mingil määral valdab, nagu et ei vaata klaatuuri,
Õpetaja: No siin on neid. Mul on kahe aja jooksul midagi tekkinud See on ka tegelikult asi, mille poole püüelda Üleüldiselt. Vahet, pole, mis töötajaid, Eriti nüüd ajastul.
Õpetaja: Mis te ikka neid klahve vaadate? Ee, võtke suvaline online keskkond lahti. Chat Ipt ei soovitab teile millist ee kasutada tasuta, Kus te hakkate pihta Niimoodi, et õpetatakse, kuidas päriselt Ee, kirjutada, et hoiad käpad siin nende peal. Millist tähte, millega vajutad, on mingid tobedad Harjutused, et
Õpetaja: tooksin seal mingeid erinevaid tähti. Ja vaata, lõpus hakkad kirjutama sõnu. Ma kunagi ei viitsisin investeerida vist arvatavasti kuskil Mingi
Õpetaja: kaks tundi Ma juba rohkem ei piitsnud. Ma kahetsen, et oleks veel rohkem juba kahe tunniga. Tegelikult niimoodi harjutades saab päris hea nagu alguse kätte.
Õpetaja: No Mõned tähed on nagu. Nagu käsi. Peab olema nagu. Mingi. Kuidas on need need kondiväänad, mis see nimi oli? Noh,
Õpetaja: jah, niuke tunne juba, et mingid tähed võib ka ikka veits vaadata. Nagu onju Keeps Fine
Õpetaja: Aga nagu printsiibis. Tegelikult. Ee, on on aeg. Kui te ei pimekirja ei valda, siis ee. Mingil kujul. See on väga okei. Kui sa selle tasemel noh vaatad, aga enamus ajast paned pidevalt, näed, et tähti Läheb nagu veits Puitu ka. Aga on nagu su sõbrad, on ju?
Õpetaja: Õpid Suht ruttu ära. Ee, siis mis räägib nüüd? Arendaja värk on Tõesti See asi, et tegelikult see on Niukene selle vennaga.
Õpetaja: Ta on natukene vaenlane Meil aga kohati. Ta on parim sõber, et on hetked Ja ajad, kus me ei sooviks keyboardiga toimetada. Tahame koodibaasis ringi sobrada vaadata, toimetada. No kui mõnus on hiirega seda teha, on ju,
Õpetaja: aga Kui me kirjutame koodi, siis me tegelikult üritaksime teha niimoodi, et me ei kasuta seda venda ainult äärmisel juhul.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd see ka, et Keyboard veel jagub, saab neid juurde, ka on ju Aga kuidas kellegil on tava? Keyboard on alati parem kui laptopi Keyboard. Sellepärast, et nupud on märksa kõrgemad. Need on mugav vajutada. Tunnetus on parem. Pluss ei ole mingisugust Fn jama.
Õpetaja: Function Keyboard. Il on surutud. Ee, paljud nupud Mitme erineva nupu alla pead Function It hoidma, alla midagi käivitada. Tegelikult on tobe, et ma selles mõttes soovitan, kes tunneb, et ta suudab selle väikse laua taga ka keyboard I panna. Siis tehke seda
Õpetaja: ee, sest et mingi etapp on teil ka see, kus te saate, oma läpaka kinni panna ja vaadata suurt monitorit silme ees, et oma koodi kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, siis on nagu niimoodi, et ega niimoodi on ikka Väga klapakas on kuidagi niimoodi ees. Siis hakkad see kaanega mängima,
Õpetaja: et kui kohe harjuta nagu Keyboard I peale ära, on tegelikult palju mõnusam Ja lihtsam jah. Ta võtab jälle ruumi laua peal. Aa, sättige lihtsalt keyboard. Nii kaugel see läpakas Nii kaugele, kui saate. Aa keyboard hiir,
Õpetaja: Aga kas keegi öelnud et siit üldse ei kasuta?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ei, arendaja ei teegi ühe kuvariga või saab ikka suur kuvar?
Õpetaja: Ei, no mul On poja olnud televiisor midagi?
Õpetaja: Ja ei. Kui sa te kuskilt tööle lähete, siis ee. On kaks valikut. Seal. Kas on kaks monitori laua peal. Või sul on üks suur monitor laua peal? Arendaja Ei tee ühe ekraaniga midagi. Sul on vaja nii mitut asja vaja. Sul on vaja spekti vaadata. Sul on koodi kirjutada. Sul on vaja brauserit vaadata.
Õpetaja: Jah, mis iganes vahet pole. Teil Noh, see on juba tööriist, on See,
Õpetaja: ee, ei terminal. Ee, et selles mõttes ei saagi tööd. Tööd ei tehta. Arendust ei tehta ammu enam mingi ühe monitoriga, See lihtsalt, Sul on kogu aeg vaja vaadata asju paralleelselt. See on juba vigade vältimiseks.
Õpetaja: Ja, ee. Noh, praegult peab saama hakkama. Mõtlen, aga soovitan Keyboard I proovida sealt kapist saab, kui sa teed puuduse veel juurde võtta. Aa, vaata, et. Ee. See hetk. Kus Te saate hakata tegema koodi Nagu ekraanil.
Õpetaja: No kui mõnus on niimoodi kirjutada Asjaga, millega sa oled juba harjunud? Ma ütlen, ka et kui siin on näiteks Forward Slash Noh, kuidas saab välja kommenteerida? Vaikimisi on Control ja Forward Slash.
Õpetaja: Kas saab kommenteerida? Näete intelli sees.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui teil on nüüd frontend is Vabandust, front. Kui te nüüd ainult läpakaga olete, on ju siis Teil on nagu see, et. Oota, kus mul see Forward Slash nupp on, Aga mul see eraldi polegi. Ta on mingi teise nupu peal.
Õpetaja: Aga kellel on tehtud? Siis Ma olen teinud Control Shift ja seitse, enamus Inimestel on seitsme pealse
Õpetaja: ee läpakal. See kaldkriips on nii
Õpetaja: Control Shift Seitse Peaks ka teil toimima, sest et see oli minu seal installer. Is. See on tegelikult ekstra seadistused. Sellega ka töötaks. Ee, ühe rea sisse välja kommenteerimine.
Õpetaja: Aga tuleme nüüd tagasi selle paragrahvi juurde, muidu me ei jõuagi kuhugi.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtan siit mingi teksti ja siis näitan ka, et paragrahv mõte on. Nüüd on see, et ma teen seda mitu korda siin niimoodi. Paragrahv on lõik.
Õpetaja: Kui mul on kakssada. Ma korra Dublitseerin Vaata, siis on kaks lõiku. Saate mõttest aru. Paragrahv lõik.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Ma jätan siis siia ühe. Näete ette näiteks, et on üks lihtsalt lõik. Siin on meie üheksakümnendat stiilis. Mida iganes,
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd järgmine näide on spänn.
Õpetaja: Keegi teab otset, Mis on spänn?
Õpetaja: Inglise keelt.
Õpetaja: Ulatus ja ulatuse mõte on see, et oletame, et meil ongi siin. See on Meie üheksakümnendate stiilis pank. Ja ma tahaksin näiteks teha üheksakümnendate stiilis. Teha. Lihtsalt punaseks.
Õpetaja: Noh, kujutame. Ma panen natukene siin teksti. Veel, Vaata Onju Et, ee, oleks. Võibolla selles mõttes natukene parem, nagu seda aru saada, et oletame, et
Õpetaja: mul on siin mingi tekst ja ma tahan just selle osa teha siin.
Õpetaja: Tahan teha punaseks või kuidas seda saab teha. Seda saabki spän i abil teha,
Õpetaja: aga seda spän i siia sisse. Ise praegult ee kirjutada. Võibolla oleks keeruline, aga. Okei, teeme ikkagi niimoodi. Näed, Võtame spänn. Kopige see siit.
Õpetaja: Pange see algus siia üheksa kümne ette
Õpetaja: ja võibolla stiilis järgi. Ee, pange veel spänn.
Õpetaja: Aga lõpu. See. See on alguse tag. Lõputag peab olema erinev, mis siin peab olema.
Õpetaja: See Foo Kaldkriips on ju? No Nüüd ongi. Kõik hakkavad otsima seal läpaka kaldkriipsu Lihtsalt teha. Mõnel on ka eraldi nupp Läpakal. Mõnel mitte
Õpetaja: Nii kui praegult midagi vaadata. Ega praegult ei saa midagi aru, et juhtus
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et me ei ole nagu sellele mingit teistsugust stiili andnud tekstile, kui on see ülejäänud tekst.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd on järgmine asi, millest ma tahan rääkida, on atribuut ehk omadus
Õpetaja: Ee. Kõik need tagid, mis Meil on enamus tag. I toetavad teatud tüüpi omadusi, mis on nagu nendele elementidele omane ja mõeldud.
Õpetaja: Absoluutselt kõikidel. Ee, niiöelda tag idel vaid pole? Kas on ühe tagiga või kahe tagiga? Aa atribuute. Kirjutame niiöelda esimese tag I sisse. No kui ongi ainult ühe tagiga element, siis Ongi ainult üks. Tag.
Õpetaja: Kui on kahe tag iga element, siis me kirjutame selle esimese tag I sisse. Me kasutame tühikut
Õpetaja: ja kuna ma Tahan mingit stiili anda sellele, et see teha ajutiselt korra punaseks. Siis ma kirjutan siia Style vaid on tab. I
Õpetaja: Ahah, nüüd on see ka asi. Vaata Ärge. Kirjutage asju alati lõpuni välja. Kui ta pakub neid
Õpetaja: niimoodi saab kiiremini, sest et ta tegi ka ühtlasi võrdusmärgi ja Ko. Jutumärgid nägite niimoodi? Kontorisseitega saab tagasi võtta. Alati näiteks. No Tuled Style tab.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd võiks panna kolor. Jälle Tab.
Õpetaja: Nägite, ta tegi Kooloni ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, ikka tab nuppu. Teate, see on Capslock. I Peal
Õpetaja: on ju kes ei tea. Ee, siin on nüüd edaspidi. Kui me Hakkame eriti tegema. Siis mul on seadistus eraldi veel ära muudetud, et ta toimis korrektselt. Aga mõned inimesed aktiveerivad seda valikut entriga. Mõned olivad Tabiga. Minu arvates tab on lihtsam sellepärast, et ta on väga lähedal. Nupp vasakule käele.
Õpetaja: Ma olen Tab I mees. No me räägime siin Käsurea mees ja Tabi mees. Ja kes on Tabi mees, kes on ee, entri mees või naine?
Õpetaja: Vahet pole.
Õpetaja: Ja siin ma annan mingi Värvi. Siin on mingisugused. Ee, Color Code Id. Niiöelda Aga ma võin ka lihtsalt kirjutada, Red, näiteks
Õpetaja: nüüd on niimoodi, et paragrahvi sees on Siin on meie
Õpetaja: üheksakümnendate stiilis. Pange neid soodsam. Ja kui tulla vaatama seda, siis saate spän I mõttest aru. Ta on ulatus
Õpetaja: nüüd see, Kuidas me üldse praegu seda stiili tegime? Ma ette rutates ütlen ära.
Õpetaja: Vanasti nii oligi stiil. Stiili. Me ei tee Html I sees, vaid, Millega me teeme stiili?
Õpetaja: Csss. Noh, milleni me jõuame ka? Loodame
Õpetaja: nii jällegi. Ma ütlen, et siin ei ole vaja mitte midagi meelde jätta. Vaata, oi, kuidas see täpselt käib. Vaata ja mis, Kuidas kirjutama peab. See pole vajalik lihtsalt nagu. Tead, et põhimõtteliselt on võimalik Mingi selline asi, onju? Rohkem Pole vaja midagi teada.
Õpetaja: Põrutame edasi. Ee, spänn. Näide paragrahvi sees. Selle tegime ära. Need to do kommentaarid. Ee, to do Kommentaar on lihtsalt niimoodi mõeldud selle jaoks, et sa saad iseendale ka näiteks jaavas,
Õpetaja: Okei? Ta ei taha siin praegu niimoodi teha, et sa Saad lihtsalt jätta endale märkmed, et mida teha. Mul ongi lihtsalt märkmed ees, Et mida me siin läbi käime?
Õpetaja: Järgmine asi on break, mida teeb. Break on tühi rida.
Õpetaja: Näete, see meie pank siin. Vaata, eriti äge pank. Praegu Nad istuvad niimoodi üksteise peal.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tuleksin praegult nende kahe vahele. Panen Br ja panen tab ja panen Control D. Nagu
Õpetaja: paar, korda siis te näete, tulevad niuksed, tühjad read.
Õpetaja: See, kui Ma kirjutan, kui ma teen Lihtsalt siin selle. Mitte ühegi elemendi sees. Ma olen küll Body sees, aga ma ei ole ühegi alameelemendi sees, Kui ma teen siin neid pühikuid,
Õpetaja: Ma võin need miljon tüki ka teha. Aga Html sööb ära. Need
Õpetaja: jätab võibolla ainult mingi ühe tühiku Või seda põhimõtteliselt see ko seda teksti tegelikult ei kirjutata kunagi. Ee, mitte ühegi täägi sisse ikkagi. Ta Peaks mingi täägi sees olema see oleks viisakas,
Õpetaja: siis on igasugused võimalused ka Edaspidi,
Õpetaja: et kui me tahame Break I teha, siis Break on niimoodi. No siin võibki teha nüüd, Niimoodi, et asjad üksteise nagu selga ei lähe. Siis lihtsalt pannakse mingi kaks Break I näiteks. Ee, siia.
Õpetaja: Selle. Siin on meie pank, onju, et mingi järgmine asi, mis me teeme, ei tule kohe selga
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Kuidas me. Ee, nüüd Breakiga on see asi? Vaata, mina ütlen seda, et me tegelikult Break I tänapäevases arendusi ei kasuta. Ma küsin, miks
Õpetaja: oskab keegi pakkuda midagi. Miks me seda elementi tegelikult kuskil enam ei kasuta.
Õpetaja: Ja sellepärast Css on stiil ja paigutus. No kui sa soovid üksteistest vahet hoida, siis sa teed seda Css iga mitte sellise asjaga. Ja nüüd jah,
Õpetaja: Võtame
Õpetaja: käed. Ei toimu,
Õpetaja: et kui sa kirjutad nagu pr ja vajutad, Nüüd tab vä
Õpetaja: Ee. Aga ennem sul toimis see Justkui panen siit.
Õpetaja: Siis teeme siis siis. Ma ei tea, kas sul on nagu midagi konkreetselt hüvitatud kuskil mingi ee asi läheks praegult siin Üleval. Ee, siuke. Ma ise teen selle vea ka kuskile Vaata Näeb seda punast. Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt ütleb, et sul on kuskil tegelikult juba Midagi nii mingi sümbol? Minutaalselt katki. Vaata, et. Ee. Ma korra proovin seda. Ei,
Õpetaja: ee, ennem toimis. Vä Selle numbril tõi Oleme korra silmas Käib.
Õpetaja: Jah, mul on niimoodi. Vaata, kuskil näed see sama. Näed, see H kuus on onju,
Õpetaja: et temal ei ole enam tema paarides
Õpetaja: ja Sul on nagu see. Kood on nagu selles mõttes katki. Vaata, et sündab. See on pätti.
Õpetaja: Ee. Tema nagu siiamaani arvab, et sa kirjutad siin kogu aeg seda ühte Pealpilijat.
Õpetaja: Ta võtab seda kui teksti. Mitte kui
Õpetaja: mitte kui. Nagu koodilina. Vaata, ta nagu põhimõtteliselt näeb. Ma panen Nagu selle koosse. Vaata, ta mõtleb, et ta tahab siukest asja teha.
Õpetaja: Tal ei ole tempo.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui me teeme siia selle lõpu praegu, Kobime selle ja paneme selle. Kirja Panen siia selle.
Õpetaja: Mis on siis nüüd juba?
Õpetaja: Aa, vot jaa. Praegult on lihtsam üldse teha korra, nagu, Noh, niimoodi. Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Panengi lihtsalt siia, üks break ja tee seda paar tükki ja tahame nagu nende järgmiste asjadega edasi. Teha.
Õpetaja: Aa, mis juhtus, oli siis see, et. Ee, noh, juhtuski. Niukene asi, mis hakkab juhtuma algatajal, ongi see, et ee, kuskilt. Näiteks siit. Võtad selle asja Ära
Õpetaja: Siis nüüd süntaksi mõttes näete. Üleval on Niukene error. Ma panen korra selle tagasi.
Õpetaja: Näitab, et on kõik on roheline, välja arvatud mingid Taipod. Noh, siin on mingit teksti. Väga palju Eesti keeles ka. Onju, et kui kuskil läheb kood, nagu see tähendab, see fail läheb süntaksi mõttes katki Siis ta annab märku. Ma võtan näiteks siit
Õpetaja: ära. Nagu mingi ühe sümboli Tuli, et on katki.
Õpetaja: Vahel Ta oskab aru saada. Ka. Vaata, et kus viga on.
Õpetaja: Või lähed selle peale nagu selle Errori peale ja siis ta ütleb
Õpetaja: ja ta viib siia reale ja Näete, siin on väikene punane joon kaal.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellega on so so. Ee. Kas ta oskab seda asja nagu.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ee, et kas Ta oskab seda asja nagu alati. Väga korrektselt. Kuvada, et mis ta arvab, et on katki või mitte onju, et see natukene sõltuv,
Õpetaja: aga Lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd. Järgmine asi, mis me tahame vaadata, on list.
Õpetaja: Tahame teha esiteks, niukse väikse heederi meie pangakontorit. Noh, paneme mingi viis, Kirjutame meie panga kontoreid.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt oleks nagu mingi visuaal ka, onju? Meie pangakontoreid. Nüüd tahame teha listi nüüd listiga. On Selline variant, et kui Me tahame Bullet pointidena. Siis kasutame niukest elementi nagu uel.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me tahame järjest ee numbreid niiöelda et üks, kaks, kolm, siis on Ol Aa, Ma ei mäletagi, kuidas nüüd võiks meelde jätta neid tähti. Aga see ei ole jälle tähtis. Ka Kunagi on vaja klotsite.
Õpetaja: Me Teeme esialgu siis Nagu Bullet point idega, et, ee, kirjutame uel. Aga nüüd on väike stop.
Õpetaja: Ee, näete siin all tema pakub vaata, et Kas sa mõtled seda? Aga all on mingisugune tempel.
Õpetaja: Ja veel on. Pluss on juures. Ma korra näitan mingi muu asjaga ruttu ennem. Näiteks H viis.
Õpetaja: Ta pakub ainult niukest elementi. Vaata, ta on nagu üksikelement. Kui te näete niukest templit ja plussi, nagu siin on, siis see näitab seda, et. Ee, see on mitmekihiline. Ee, element.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole Vot. Siiamaani on olnud põhimõtteliselt üks rida ja mingi asi on vahel, Mis me oleme teinud? Kui nüüd tulla seda ja valida, siis tuleb noole kala alla tulla. Niimoodi, Ee, hiirega ei hakka siin ometi mässama, vaid ta tab.
Õpetaja: Siis näete, mis ta tegi. Ta tegi niimoodi, et kõigepealt on meil Ee, Bullet Pointide list
Õpetaja: algab Pullen Pointide list lõppeb Ja nüüd tema sees, selle skoobi vahel.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma võtan selle vahelt ära
Õpetaja: tema sees on veel eraldi element. List ja list. List Item Eli.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia. Näiteks Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Siis on Tallinn Pullen Point. Iga on nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui ma tahaksin teha Tartut, kuidas ma seda Hästi, odavalt saaks praegult teha tellisega
Õpetaja: Control D. Nii, aga nüüd on. Niimoodi. Vaata, nüüd oleks vaja sealt tallinn aseda Tartuga on nii
Õpetaja: nüüd On nagu see, et kuidas nüüd edasi teha. No, üks variant oleks niimoodi, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga teine variant on nüüd see kurikuulus, millest ma ennem Rääkisin, et kuidas selekteerida teksti. Kui ma olen kuskil
Õpetaja: selle Control kaks Is World Select Word.
Õpetaja: Kui vajutan ühe korra veel, peale, pakkuge, mis siis juhtub ega läheb laiemaks.
Õpetaja: Kui ma vajutan veel ühe korra läheb laiemaks. Läheb laiemaks. Läheb laiemaks. Näete, kui ma tahaks tagurpidi, siis tihtipeale Shift on see variant. Control Shift ja sama nupp uuesti. Vaata
Õpetaja: aga, vot see on nüüd see, mida ma ütlen, et see on nagu Väga Dangerous. Asi, mida nagu endale kätte harjutada.
Õpetaja: Sest et varem või hiljem siis see juhtub. Siis Ta on nagu. Aa, nüüd ma tean, Mida Rain mõtles?
Õpetaja: Aga mina elu sees. Kui ma. Kui ma tahaks seda võimalikult ruttu teha, ma tulengi. See on kontroll. T Istun siin kenasti vahel. Kontroll kaksisv ja nüüd. Juba kirjutan lihtsalt Tartu
Õpetaja: ja kirjutab selle üle. Vaadake, kui kiiret saad teha. Aga noh, see oleks normaalne.
Õpetaja: Teeme veel ühe. Ma panen viljandi ka. Kontrol kaks siis V viljandi.
Õpetaja: Nii, okei, ee. Vaatan, kas mul korra veel on Kuskil lahti ka
Õpetaja: Ee Knowledge Base. Ma lähen pigem aa Ära siit. Aa,
Õpetaja: ee. Teise Space alla. Vali idee.
Õpetaja: Ee, Lähen otsin siit Ee shortcut Id
Õpetaja: Ma Olen teinud kõikidest enam kasutatavatest Ee, shortcut idest sellise lehe Shorcut Id.
Õpetaja: Siin on väga lühikesed videod. No Vaatame Select Word selekteerib sõna kursori Hetkekohast. Mitmekordsel vajutusel laieneb sektsioon väljapoole.
Õpetaja: Parabimber A Boom.
Õpetaja: Maailma kõige lühem video. Vau, üks nelikümmend üheksa.
Õpetaja: Põhimõtteliselt ma olen teinud selle ära, et Kuidas see asi toimib?
Õpetaja: Mida see teeb, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Et teil on, ee olemas. Ee, kõik kenasti.
Õpetaja: Võin visata praegu siia Lingi. Kui tahate,
Õpetaja: võite selle ise üles otsida. Teil on kõigil ligipääs olemas. Palun, Vaadake, kui mina samamoodi ma, kui ma kunagi, ee hakkasin kasutama. Ja ma sain aru seda tüütut asja, et käpad küljest ära vaata Siis ma võtsin Youtubei. Läksin otsima,
Õpetaja: Leidsin sealt mingisuguse ee live Presentatsiooni, kus keegi, inimene näitas igasuguseid asju. Palun investeerige aega. Ee, nendesse tööriistadesse. Kui teil on plaanis nende tööriistadega aega teha, et natukene uurida, Mida kõike saab teha. Kuidas
Õpetaja: Te kulutate aega, aga te võidate selle. Tagasi.
Õpetaja: Te saate kõik selle tagasi tuhandekordselt. Lõpuks
Õpetaja: Ee samamoodi. Ee, võtke see aeg. Vaadake juba need asjad läbi Vaata jääb veits meelde. Ee, alguses on jõle palju asju, mida meeles hoida. Aga uskuge mind, kuidas saab selle asja lõpuks käpa niimoodi. See on hästi lihtne süsteem.
Õpetaja: Iga kord, kui sa hakkad midagi tegema ja sa, ee, tunned, et sa, Sul on vaja midagi teha ja sa tahad tõsta hi käpa hirvele panna? Siis mõtle korra. Kas seda teoreetiliselt on võimalik teha käsitsi ja Kas sa sooviksid seda teha käsitsi?
Õpetaja: Kui on, siis sa uurid välja. Vaata, kuidas seda saab teha. Vaata, onju. Või Tuletad meelde, et sa Tegelt juba tead, et sa saad teha või sa ei mäleta. Kuidas siis sa teed niimoodi? Sa karistad ennast selles mõttes, Vaata, on see, Et sa ei haara seda hirt. Või kui sa seda hiire haarad, ainult siis selle jaoks, et minna ja otsida üles, vaata, kuidas seda Sa ei tea, Noh, saab ka hästi kiirelt öelda,
Õpetaja: aga point on siis, see, et siis kasutad seda varianti, lähed, vaatad, kuidas sa seda käsitsi teha. Teed käsitsi
Õpetaja: sa sul. See juhtub arvatavasti kuskil No kolm, neli korda ja siis asju öelda ka, et sulle jääb meelde,
Õpetaja: et Kui see on distsipliin hästi lihtne ja kiire, on sel hetkel haarata hiir ja teha see ära. Raske. Ee vaevarikas tüütu. Ma teen mingit asja minna, otsida, Vaadata, kuidas seda sai asja teha. Keyboardiga võtab aega, aga see jääb meelde. See jääb meelde.
Õpetaja: Mul on paljud asjad kui Keegi küsib näiteks. Ma ei oska peast öelda. Ee, et kuidas saab teha. Aga kui mul on keyboard Id peal, siis mu käed teevad selle lihtsalt ära ma vahel visualiseerin ja endale mõtlengi, et
Õpetaja: vajutan nuppe. Ja siis ütlen, et vist nii saab.
Õpetaja: Vot nii, no saime siukse Listi,
Õpetaja: Okei? Ja kui me nüüd muudame selle Ul i siit niimoodi. See võib olla vaatamise koht ka. Panen ol iks,
Õpetaja: siis Mis juhtub, on see, et nad on nüüd numbri korral küpsed. Variandid
Õpetaja: lähme. Edasi ee. Kommentaarid, võib ära kustutada paneme. Siia jälle ühe breigi või isegi, Kaks pilt.
Õpetaja: Ee, See on nüüd esimene element, mis meil on Ühe tagiga image Pimg.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on ka oma templid. Aga nagu näha ühtegi Plussi pole mitmekihiline Ta pole, aga ta pakub paari varianti. Kas te näete siin paremal? Pool on hallilt mingisugused väiksed näidised, ka et tavaline Image tähendab seda, et on. Ee, mäletate seda siin, kus me tegime selle spänni ja Style?
Õpetaja: Vaadake, ta on ju Tegelikult, ta on elemendi Sees vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: See on atribuut.
Õpetaja: Siin on niimoodi image. Iga on näha. Vaata ka, et image tegelikult standardina ootab sisse mõningaid atribuute ja Siin on mingid erinevad variandid. Ee, Source. See tavaline kõige lihtsam meile. Image Source
Õpetaja: Selle tabiga valin nüüd. Source on, see. Et Hei, kust ma selle pildi sisu saan
Õpetaja: Alt on siis selline asi, mis on mõeldud seda, et juhul, kui seda sisu ei saa renderdada mingil põhjusel, Siis näidatakse katkise pildi ikooni ja tuleb mingisugune tekst.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei ole ainus asi, kus seda kasutatakse. Ee, vaegnägijatel on igasugused vahvad programmid Ja asjad, mis Brauserist
Õpetaja: suudavad aru saada, kus nad on. Liiguvad seal tabiga, liiguvad seal hiirega. Vahet pole. Vaata, et kui sul läheb mingi pildi peale, siis Tegelikult see kõne Süntesaator saab talle ka öelda, et siin on Lhv pangakontoreid kaart.
Õpetaja: Võibolla mitte niisuguse häälega, aga umbes nii, Ee, aga ka siis, nagu ma ütlesin, kui pilt mingil põhjusel ei renderdaad tekst, et nagu mis representeerib seda
Õpetaja: see nüüd, on niimoodi, et See Ei, ole otseselt kohustuslik element. Kui ma võtan selle ära, siis tuleb alla Kollane joon
Õpetaja: Kollane tähendab seda et See, on Warning. Näete, Siin on Warning tuli. See ei ole katki,
Õpetaja: aga on Hea tava, et sul on ikka nagu mingi tekst, ka juhul kui pilt on katki või kui pime soovib kuulda, mis siin toimub.
Õpetaja: No vaatame, kas ta midagi ütleb ka selle kohta. Vaata rohkemat, kui Ma Ee selle Aldi, ära kustutan. Ee, kas ta ütleb ka midagi?
Õpetaja: Aa placement for image which is mandatory and incredibil used for accessibility screen readers read Attribute values out to the users so they know what the image meanch. Noh, Ongi see, et nagu ma ei näe, aga ma kuulen,
Õpetaja: et ta rääkis siin selle ka põhimõtteliselt välja. Nüüd sorsiga on niimoodi. Et Kõigepealt teeme niimoodi. Et pildi võtame väliselt, et projektiväliselt Ee, teen lahti. Tehke ka kaasa. Teen lahti ja otsin sõna. Kaart
Õpetaja: ei lähe neti punkt eesse.
Õpetaja: Pange kohe aadressi reale. Siit ülevalt. Võtan pildid.
Õpetaja: No Võtan näiteks selle kaardi siin. Noh, see on Niukene Hea kaart. Eestimaa kaart Trikin Selle peale.
Õpetaja: Siin on pilt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ma teen parema klõpsu siia peale ja panen copy. Aa, kus image adress on? Kuskil või Copy Image adres. Näete seda siin
Õpetaja: kui ma võtan nüüd korra, kontrolliks Ühe Uue Tab I lahti ja paistin selle siia. Siis siia. Peaks ilmuma pilt lihtsalt. See on selle pildi aadress,
Õpetaja: Nii, ja meie emissioon on nüüd see, et me ütleme, et see pilt, Kui praegu ma lähen. Nagu vaatan seda lehte. Siin ei ole mingit pilti, mis? Sest, et mul on imidž, aga tal ei ole mingit sisu.
Õpetaja: Aa, teeme korra testi ka. Vaata, Panen siia. Olen vaene nägija.
Õpetaja: Nii kui ma praegu Tulen siia, siis ta näitab, et pilt on katki. Sisu pole aga näitab teksti. Kas see alt nüüd muutus teile tähendusrikkaks,
Õpetaja: kuidas on See mõeldud.
Õpetaja: Kui pilt ei suuda rendendada,
Õpetaja: näidatakse seda teksti. Pluss, kui pilte suudetakse renderdada. Taustal, on see info Olemas Screen Reader loeb selle välja. Kui nüüd see link, mis ma nagu sealt sain, on Kindlalt viim Mis tahes. Pildile panen. Control Vep
Õpetaja: tuleb Niukene Pikk joru tuleb Siia on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui pilt on Mingi monster suur, siis ta võibolla võtta kogu lehe ära.
Õpetaja: Siis ma saan teha niimoodi, et, ee, ma Kasutan veel ühte atribuuti. Tulen siia ette
Õpetaja: ma ei viitsi otsida. Kus see lõppeb. Praegu seal. Tulen siia ette ja panen. Kas Olif Kaksteisv?
Õpetaja: Ütlen, et näiteks viiskümmend pikslit,
Õpetaja: Siis on see väga väike pilt, kui ma panen ee, kakssada pikslit. No see on mingi niuke pilt, saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd. Sellega on ka seda. Tegelikult ei tasuks kunagi nii teha vaid Kuidas Css is Jah,
Õpetaja: no ma panen näiteks mingi Viissada siis praegu. Ma ei tea, Tundub enam mingi pilt. Mõte on selge pilt.
Õpetaja: Aga praegult on niimoodi et see, source see sisu on Ee defineeritud, et see tuleb kuskilt väljastpoolt. Väga tavaline lähenemine ka. Päriselus,
Õpetaja: et on mingisugused eraldi teenused, kus ee. Saab väga mugavalt Hoida. Näiteks pilte. Võibolla neid dubleeritakse. Seal Tehakse suuruses pilt. Medium size pilt, eriti suur pilt.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja võibolla meie meie tarkvara, Meie leht siis soovib Vastavalt olukorrale laadida
Õpetaja: internetist neid samu pilte, mis on meie enda pildid, on ju Aga võibolla erinevas suuruses, et ee hoida seal võibolla näiteks mahtu kokku seal kohas, kus ei ole vaja väga suurt pilti. Ee, nagu et mis see pilt päriselt taustal on? Kui suur ta on, On ju midagi taolist?
Õpetaja: Nüüd võiks teha niukse triki, et selle sama pildi võiks tegelikult Aa ära salvestada. Arvutisse.
Õpetaja: See image jazz,
Õpetaja: see võib olla ka puhtalt vaatamise koht. Ma panen kuskile downloads ka. Osta selle endale. Panen siia mingi nime. Panen näiteks
Õpetaja: kaart.
Õpetaja: Äge Card Already exist I guess I dony before
Õpetaja: ee do wanna replaced. Noh, by your means.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ma saan teha niimoodi, et ee ma teen korra Browseri lahti.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui see kaart on nüüd siin, siis
Õpetaja: näe. Teda. Teeme niimoodi, et. Ee, ma järjestan Date. Modify D kaart.
Õpetaja: Tule, ma Arvan Control C ehk võib ka vanakooli värki teha. Parem klõps ja. Aa, siin. Oo, okei, väga hea, aga, no lihtsam. On muidugi Control C.
Õpetaja: Tulen. Teen selle projekti lahti, et siia saab neid faile samamoodi. Võtan näiteks Aa Frontend. Ist lahti. Public tausta ja panen näiteks siia
Õpetaja: Control E kaart
Õpetaja: küsib, kus tahan Kit I lisada. Noh, mina ei tea, Whatever. Nii kui ennem prügikasti läheb, võin panna Ad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see kaart siin ja kustutan korra selle rea Ära üldse. Aa, teen ta näiteks siniseks.
Õpetaja: Siin on väike trikk ka. Mida teeb kontroll X Tavaliselt,
Õpetaja: ee. Kui kirjutad mingi tekstidokument või midagi taolist. Cut. See tähendab seda, et ta võtab mingi otsa tekstist ära, aga see on mälus, on nii? Võtab mingi sõna.
Õpetaja: Minu kõige odavam viis. Tegelikult on eraldi Nupp on kontroll. Yon. Mis, kustutab muidu aga, ma ei viitsi nagu, Ei ole ka midagi muud On, Ee, täpselt. Ei mäleta, kuidas ma hästi odavalt kustutan. Näiteks, ma olen kuskil siin. Real Panen kontroll X.
Õpetaja: Ma tegelt tahtsin teda kustutada, aga ma ei viitsi. Vaata, otsida õiget Nuppu. Hästi, teed mingi osa siniseks kontrolliks. Ainukene asi on see, vaata, Et ee, et nüüd on ta mälus,
Õpetaja: et kui ma tahan nagu päriselt seda asja nagu mällu saada
Õpetaja: ja siis seda asja tahan kustutada, et siia asemele panna. Kui aitad kontroll X uuesti ja siis mul ei ole seda vana asja enam mälus, et kui ma lõpuks panen Kontroll vee. Vaata, Onju, et siis tal on viimane asi meeles,
Õpetaja: aga niimoodi saab põhimõtteliselt kustutada. Ma kustutan selle rutu ära. Sa hakkad lihtsalt siniseks ja delik vajutada, mida iganes. Ma tahan seda imedžit korra uuesti teha. Aga nüüd ma tahan, niimoodi. Et Source ei lähe mitte link, mis asub kuskil väljaspool vaid see sama fail, mis on mul serveris olemas. Minu enda projektis.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd ma ei tea, kuidas on kataloog vist ongi. Jumal teab, kus ta on. Tegelikult, kui ma panen praegult kontroll. Tühik.
Õpetaja: Ee, me pakume sellist asja, kui ma panen kaldkriips.
Õpetaja: Kontroll Tühik ja kaart. Kas see töötab või mitte? Kohe vaatan.
Õpetaja: No tuli tagasi.
Õpetaja: Et ma ütlen niimoodi. See See on niimoodi. Põhimõtteliselt vist, et Ta kohtleb seda kausta kui juurkataloog.
Õpetaja: Mis iganes siin sees on. No kui ma paneksin siia näiteks selle teise faili paavi. No see on See ikoon,
Õpetaja: mis on siin üle, mis on ka tegelikult Browser is.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttes aru. On ju, et et meil saab kahtepidi olla meil. Kas need pildid on niiöelda päriselt?
Õpetaja: Ee, meie enda serveris olemas
Õpetaja: või? Nad asuvad kuskil serveris ja kolmas variant on see, et need andmed tulevad andmebaasis. Seda vaatame siis, kui me jõuame päris
Õpetaja: päris asjaga alustada, et kuidas pilt tuleb Andmebaasist
Õpetaja: ja pilt Tegelikult taustal on ka päeva Lõpuks nullid ja vähe. Ei ole niimoodi, et lähed Facebooki ja paned sinna mingi story sse. Paned, et upload mingi äge pilt, Vaata, kus Ma olen mingi veinikaasiga kuskil
Õpetaja: Ee, päikeseloojangul. Binchil on ju, et siis ei ole niimoodi, et kuidagi läbi selle data kaabli läheb nagu päris Pilt nagu mingi kohale. Lähevad Ainult andmed kohale. Pilt on ju samamoodi. Tegelikult päeva lõpuks. Nullid ja ühed, nagu kõik muu, mis me siin Näeme on ka enda nii.
Õpetaja: Okei, Ee, see on olemas. On see pilt? Aga ma selle pildi üldse kustutan. Ära ta jääb, see kuidagi sealt ette nagu, ee, virelema
Õpetaja: järgmine asi võiks teha niukse tabeli. Kus on siis Aa veeru teesnimi perekonnanimi ja see on paar paar niiöelda
Õpetaja: Ee, klienti. Noh, ee, Juku. Ja Juhan ja Rain tüür Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis see element ise on kabel,
Õpetaja: Kui ma juba hakkan kirjutama siit, mille ma võiksin valida ja miks
Õpetaja: teeb pluss. Aga miks sa tee pealt pluss see on nagu template ehk nagu mall, aga Mis see pluss tähendab?
Õpetaja: Lisandub.
Õpetaja: Tal on, ee, mitmekihiline. Ta ei ole lihtsalt ühe tagiga. Ta on nagu sügavam.
Õpetaja: Vajutan entrit. Oh, saab samamoodi Näeme, et ta tegi niukse elemendi nagu table. Tabel algab. Tabel lõppeb on nii?
Õpetaja: Mis see Tr võiks olla, kui tegemist on tabeliga Table Row, See siin on üks rida.
Õpetaja: Ja mis see tee idee võiks olla? Keegi teab äkki
Õpetaja: ma võin öelda, kohe arvada, et ta tegelikult, Kuidas tee pealt, Data? Aga kuidas ta transleerub? On tegelikult Veerg.
Õpetaja: Ehk Siis Praegult on üks rida ja veergi üks, kui meie eesmärk on teha. Tabel, kus on kaks veergu, eesnimi ja perekonnanimi. Siis mis ma siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Eesnimi Tuled siia, Vaatad. Ega tal mingeid bordereid ega asju pole. Vaata, on eesnimi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaks teha teist veergu talle kõrvale, siis kuidas ma teen mismoodi? Mida on teil mingeid ideid?
Õpetaja: Mm, Control D. Meil on vaja tegelikult, et selle ühe rose sees on kaks veergu. Noh, Control D,
Õpetaja: Control, kaks, isv ja kirjutad siia perekonna nimi
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on meil põhimõtteliselt tabel rida. Üks
Õpetaja: Veerg, üks veerg, kaks visuaalis. On Eesti nimi. Perekonnanimi.
Õpetaja: Kui ma nüüd tahaksin päriselt siia teha, ka. Siis ee, rain tüür. Nagu siia alla kande.
Õpetaja: No Ma teen ruttu siia väikse heederi ka, juurde, et see kuidagi oleks miiningful mingi Ee, h neli Ja panen mingi meie kliendid.
Õpetaja: Noh, need on meie kliendid.
Õpetaja: Siis Kui koodi mõttes. Ma tahan nüüd teha nagu siia rain tüüris mis ma peaks tegema Eriti kõige lihtsamalt.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab teha juurde?
Õpetaja: Noh, see siin on ka enda Nagu rida. Üks on ju?
Õpetaja: On Kellegil mingi mõte.
Õpetaja: Kuulge, meil siin kursusel vist olid mingid inimesed, kes ütlesid on mingid Ee Frondispetsialistid. Kus nad nüüd on, nagu
Õpetaja: okei aus Aus Tegelikult aus. Muidugi, ärge öelge, see on igav.
Õpetaja: No, kes pakub. Mis ma koodi mõttes peaks tegema? Mis, kuidas, ma. Mis ma muudan? Ma olen uus algaja. Aidake mind, palun.
Õpetaja: Break vä. Ei, ma ei taha tühtsust teha. Ma ei ole üks rida juurde.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga paneme Nüüd selle kirja ka. Kuidas saab ühe rea juurde?
Õpetaja: Kuhu ma kirjutan? Thr? Mis Reale Vasakul pool on? Ee, koodirea numbrid.
Õpetaja: Kuhu ma kirjutan Kolmkümmend kolmkümmend, kuus. Kanda on ju, et. Ee, siia. Tr on ju.
Õpetaja: No siin tasuks valida. Tr, milline pluss.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on nüüd sa Siis kirjuta siia. Rain
Õpetaja: saaks teha, sest tublikaadi ja panna, et tüür on nii tuli.
Õpetaja: Aga kui mõelda seda, et kui saaks seda väga odavalt ja kiirelt teha. Siis saaks teha, niimoodi. Et Nüüd ma näitan teile. Ma korra võtan hiire kasutusele. Vaata, et ee, mõte oleks siis, See, et kas ostaks tõele, et seda oleks vaja dubleerida.
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu vajaksin. Muidugi, kontroll. Tee. Vaata, siis tuleks Täpselt selline. Asi. Kas sellele asjale siia otsa ma korra vajutan, Kontroll T,
Õpetaja: et siin on nagu, et. Oi, Aga see läks nagu eelmisele reale, et kui te kunagi. Mitut rida niiöelda selekteerite ja duubeldate või kopite, siis tehke niimoodi, et ärge võtke ainult need read, vaid võtke ka reavahetust niimoodi,
Õpetaja: kui Nüüd dubleerid, siis ta läheb.
Õpetaja: Püraki
Õpetaja: Noh, siia siis juba Tuleks Klikiga Paneks Rain siia. Tuleks alla. Kontroll, kaksisv tüür. Noh, võib oma nime panna. Mis iganes mõte on, selge.
Õpetaja: No ja kui ma tahaksin veel teha niukest asja, siis saaksin Ma saaksin ka juba niimoodi, teha et, Ee,
Õpetaja: no nime saab ka Vaata, peaasi, et see reavahetus. Vaata, kus Kus see kursaarg liigub. Ma. Kuidas mina nagu teen Keyboardiga. Seda on See, et mul nooltega nagu mässan. Sellega on ju, et Kuhu ma. Ta panen.
Õpetaja: Hoiad shift I peal ja hakkad noolega alla tulema. Niimoodi,
Õpetaja: Control D. No ja teeme veel. See on kõik, onju? Panen siia Juku.
Õpetaja: Juku. Juhan Annete laps.
Õpetaja: Ma Ütlen saate aru, Tabel Okei, no Siin ei ole neid bordereid ja asju juures. Aga printsiibist saate aru?
Õpetaja: Ee, et ta visuaalselt et ta tabel on
Õpetaja: Nii, Meie kliendid on Ära tehtud, Vaatame järgmiseks. Nüüd tuleb ee. Esimene niukene veits. Interaktiivsem asi. Input
Õpetaja: imp.
Õpetaja: Siit võiks võtta selle esimese malli tavaline inpot
Õpetaja: vaikimise iga Input on tüübilt tekst. Vaadake, nüüd on. Meil on nüüd ühe tagiga.
Õpetaja: Ta on ühe tagiga. Tal ei ole lõppu. Tal ei ole skoopi, Tal ei ole ulatus. Tema sees on atribuudid. Noh, kui käsitsi kirjutada. Tal peab olema tüüp,
Õpetaja: mis vaikimisi praegult on tekst.
Õpetaja: See teine oli Mis siit juba kaduma läks? Võib ära kustutada. Pole neid siin selles. Ee, siin selles koobis. Hetkel ei ole neid kuidagi vaja. Hiljem hiljem läheb vaja. Tegelikult toota, mis peaks justkui olema.
Õpetaja: Ee, okei, teeme selle ka. Paneme siia, ette H, neli ja paneme lisa. Uus klient.
Õpetaja: Teeme Nii,
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd paneme siiski sellele asjale ühe asja juurde. Juba ettenägelikud. Mitte Name I, aga paneme Id,
Õpetaja: kui kui oled. Juba jõudsalt ära, Kui sa lihtsalt kirjutad Id ja Tab ja ta tuleb siia.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see saab olema. Aa, selle Id Ga on niimoodi Aa, It võib olla ühes Html dokumendis ainult ühe ja ainsa korra ühe samasuguse väärtusega. See on põhimõtteliselt. Me tahame nagu põhimõtteliselt panna siia aa mingisuguse. Okei, Me paneme. Teeme natuke nagu ära. Pikemalt.
Õpetaja: Praegult on see kast. Vaata. Ee, paneme siia kasti ette ka mingisuguse sildi, et mis siin kasti Sees peaks käima.
Õpetaja: Ee, tuleme siia. Lase Igor alla. Ma korra ära lasta. Korraks Anna ära. Ma kirjutan siia. Label
Õpetaja: tasub valida jälle. See
Õpetaja: Jah, võib võtta tegelt. Foori võtab korraks ära Tegelt. Ta võib jääda. Las ta olla korraks. Label on siia. Ma panen ees nimi,
Õpetaja: et Lisa uus klient Ee, eesnimi ja siia kasti. Siis saaks kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, siia saaks siis kirjutada. Rain, onju?
Õpetaja: Raini pole. Rain on juba olemas. Meil siin klientidena. Oletame, et siia tuleb. Siis ma ei tea mingi madis saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Nii, teeme niukest kastikest.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd. Mis selle Labeliga on? Vaata, et see kast on meil tegelikult siin olemas. See on see osa siin,
Õpetaja: Kui me kunagi tahaksime programmiliselt pöörduda selle kasti poole, et saada seda sisu kätte, siis on meil vaja mingit pidepunkti. Kuidas me saame viidata just sellele kastile sellepärast, et kui meil on praegu siin label eesnimi. Ee, ja me teeme siia juurde ka perekonnanimi. Ja näiteks mingi vanus on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, siis lõpuks meil on neid kaste siin lehel? Mingi, võibolla mitmeid. Aga kuidas ma programmiliselt saan viidata Sellele kastile ongi see Id.
Õpetaja: Panen Id.
Õpetaja: No kui see, on ee, Nüüd mingisugune. Ee, selle asja nimi on muutuja.
Õpetaja: Mingisugune sildikene. Mis võiks olla sildikene, mis viitab eesnimele. Mis võiks olla selle sildi nimi
Õpetaja: Kuidas Ma saaksin pärast programmis öelda, et. Ei, ma mõtlen just seda. Asja.
Õpetaja: Mis mõte ta. On Meil vaja silti külge panna, et ma saaks hiljem sellele viidata. Kuidagi.
Õpetaja: No kui see on eesnimi, siis loomulikult. Kui sisu võib olla Eesti keelne, siis koodi kirjutatakse alati inglise keeles,
Õpetaja: Siis Mina paneks siia First Name ja Camel. Case.
Õpetaja: Ahah, Võibolla see on hea koht, kus ee. Korra
Õpetaja: ee vaadata. Veidi teooriamaterjale, mis on teil ka olemas.
Õpetaja: Search. Iga läheb ülesse.
Õpetaja: Naming Conventions java Naming Conventions Code formating Best practices
Õpetaja: Ee. Kas te. Kas ma viskan neid linke Võibolla Chat I ka saate pärast hiljem vaadata. Selline nimi
Õpetaja: ja selline link. No, keegi on siia kunagi pannud.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, Staff.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma korra Küsin selle. Aa, tegelt on niimoodi. Pole mõtet. Aa, ma editin eelmist niimoodi
Õpetaja: käsi püsti kes jõudis eelkursust? Ee, veidi vaadata ja midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, mõned inimesed on midagi veitsite veidi, onju? Sealt. Tegelikult kõik need materjalid Aa tulevad riburada pidi. Aa, kellel ei ole kellel on võibolla Võimalus peale seda koolitust tegelikult tahaks hakata veidi uuesti vaatama kõike asju ja natuke suurema detailsusega rahulikuma tempoga.
Õpetaja: Soovitan seda koolitust tegelikult hiljem läbi teha, aga võibolla ei pea kõiki harjutusi ja asju tegema nagu kaasa. See on juba Below Your level. Pigem nagu teoreetiline pool.
Õpetaja: Ee, täitsa Mõeldav tegevus.
Õpetaja: Vaatame, mis meil korra siin räägitakse. Ee, Räägitakse sellest, et on erinevad kirjaviisid
Õpetaja: Camel Case. Noh, paskalis ta kunagi tuli. Paskal oli Esimene, kes selle mõtles, on see, et kuidas eristada nagu, aa, teatud koodilõikudes. Nagu mitmesõnalisi asju,
Õpetaja: nagu niimoodi, et oleks silmal võimalik aru saada, et on mitu sõna. Aga seal on lihtsalt tingimused, et need tähed peavad kõik olema üksteisega seotud. Sa Ei, saa kirju tühikut ei saa panna ei saa panna. My Class
Õpetaja: tühikuga ei tööta. Kahe küüriga on see, et esimene täht algab juba suure tähega kõik tähed on eraldatud Suure tähega.
Õpetaja: Ühe küüruga Kaamel. On siin mingid näited Ka klassi nimed, head. Ja siis on Lowercase Camer Case. Noh, ühe küüruga kaamel ehk siis tegelikult, et kõik sõnad on eraldatud suure tähega. Aga esimene täht algab väikse tähega.
Õpetaja: Sneakash siin. No, siin on väiksed pildid ka juures Saate mõttest aru. Sõnu eraldatakse alakriipsuga.
Õpetaja: Ee, Snake Case on siis lihtsalt sama asi. Ainult suurte tähtedega. Ikka see väike uss, vaata onju
Õpetaja: ja kebab Case. Pigem on nagu grill varas.
Õpetaja: Ja siin on see mõte. On see, et on sidekriipsud.
Õpetaja: Vahel on ju nii tähed sidekriipsud, tähed, Tekst sõna, sidekriips. Sõna. Sidekriips on Nii suurt lihtne meeles hoida.
Õpetaja: Aa, nüüd meil siin see sildikene.
Õpetaja: Ee, Traditsiooniliselt olekski siis Lower Ee Camel Case First name.
Õpetaja: Kas Pliiats kukub, Läheb lõunale.
Õpetaja: Vasakas kukub või? Teeme veel siis Ee, kaks kasti ära. Veel
Õpetaja: isegi selles osas keegi ei oska midagi ei kasta.
Õpetaja: Raske. No Davai. Tundub, et teil on vaja seda pastakas kuku värki. Ee, mina panen ee zoomi. Panen Aa stopi peale,
Õpetaja: et Ee taustal see video saaks renderdama hakata.
Õpetaja: Ee, stop share I Võin ka panna. Aidake siis meeles hoida.